not be exacting any bills today
so if somebody's hanging around to hear
us exact something that's not going to
occur today we will be executing bills
on Friday it's noted as hearing day but
those bills will be announced on the
floor tomorrow uh so we will be exacting
okay
yeah
foreign
we're starting out today without House
Bill 331 relative to the income
threshold for the education Freedom
account program welcome representative
leckis
thank you chairman
Alicia lekkas Hillsboro 38 Hudson and
Litchfield
and I want to start out by saying when
we first designed the efas we designed
them without a cap
the intent was that they were open to
every kid in the state
because
they're all our kids
and we need to make sure they all have
the opportunity for an adequate
education
all of their parents pay taxes
we do not have means testing for public
schools why should we have means testing
for this this is the opportune this is
the money for the opportunity for an
adequate education
it is per student
it should follow each student wherever
they go
it's not the whole shebang it's not
everything it costs to send a kid to
school it is just the state money
to give the opportunity for an adequate
education for every child in the state
and so therefore this was designed so
that every child can get it and that's
what this bill does it just gets rid of
the cap that got added later
and puts it back to the way it was
originally
um
and I think that's basically the meat of
what I have to say but I will be happy
to take questions thank you very much
representative are there any questions
representative miler
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
I guess I have a different uh
perspective on the origin of the EFA
accounts
it's my understanding
that when the commissioner proposed this
to the finance committee
that he basically focused on the issue
of providing an opportunity for those
parents who are within the poverty
threshold of 300 percent of poverty
that would allow them an opportunity to
seek additional funding so that their
children could go to a private or a
religious school
that's my understanding
when the commissioner presented it
this proposal
is contrary then wouldn't you agree that
this proposal is contrary to the initial
proposal of trying to help impoverished
families to have additional money to go
to private and religious schools well
clearly it's it's opposing what your
original understanding was but there
were a lot of us worked on this bill for
months I do not know what the
commissioner said before Finance but I I
because I was not there but I was there
when this bill was being worked on
tweaked discussed I attended trainings
on it beforehand this bill was around a
long time before the commissioner
presented anything to finance and in its
original form and the form as it first
came to the house there was no cap
further questions representative Belcher
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
um given the Supreme Court decision that
requires New Hampshire to provide an
adequate education to all students
would you believe that we are in line
with that decision if we are withholding
These funds based on any criteria to any
can you see that last part again we are
in line or out do you think we we are
currently following the sentiment of
that decision by prohibiting certain
students from participating in this
program personally I don't think so and
I talked with one of the representatives
who was uh who was around at the time
who was who had come up with the
original adequacy
and he said it was intended for every
student thank you
further questions representative
woodcock
good morning thank you chairman well oh
good to see her again let's wait till
that way um there's a couple quick ones
uh
when the EFA program uh initially
arrived here where did it come from and
was that something you thought up where
did that program come from that program
came
from quite a few different reps there
were a lot who worked together I mean
did it come from New Hampshire or
someone that created somewhere else we
brought it in oh no this isn't program
this is entirely New Hampshire we did a
lot of studying of what had happened in
other states through the years of
various things and we learned a lot and
we said well we're not going to do that
and we're not going to do that and oh
this seems to be effective in work and
we're not going to do that and
um but this was New Hampshire and
everybody was looking at us and our EFA
program because it was different than
what other states had done because we
had learned a lot and fixed a lot
on it you looked at may I follow up
thank you yes please so you look at the
other ones and then sort of called out
I don't know if that's the way to put it
in there are others like rep cordelli
might give you a little more history but
that's
um because he I believe he was one of
the original sponsors but I was there
were a whole lot of us who were giving
input before it actually came out in its
final form just one more information
keep it quick
yes sir
um I'm looking at the financial note and
it says indeterminable
um when the program started a few years
ago it was 129 000 and then it's gone
through multi Millions already
um so what would that look like in your
mind uh if it's for only in year three
and it's already twenty thirty thousand
million what so that says to me is that
there's a serious need for this and it's
very popular and so I think allowing it
to expand to fill the need because there
is a need not everybody can get an
adequate education at their local public
school not to say that their local
public school is bad it's just that
they're designed for one size fits all
and it just turns out to be one size
fits many and so there are kids for whom
it doesn't work so we give them an
opportunity to find what does work for
them oh you don't have a price tag the
answer I don't there's no way to predict
that that's right and determine the
questions from the committee
representative Allison oh thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking my question
very quickly does the Department of
Education support this Bill yes
thank you further questions from the
committee
represent Belcher thank you Mr chair I
just wanted to clarify because we've
heard some talk about the cost of this
can you give a rough estimate of what
we're providing per student for an EFA
program versus the average cost to
educate a child in New Hampshire Public
School well the average
EFA currently is about 4 700 and the
average total cost is about 20 000 19 to
20 000. so it actually ends up much
cheaper to educate a student this way
but as you take the cap off that average
is going to go down because since we
have the 300 percent
Mo that means those kids are all qualify
for the free and reduced lunch
or a good portion of them do at any rate
the free and reduced lunch kick in so
that raises it to 4 700 but if you have
kids above that level they're not going
to be at that they're going to be closer
to the 37 or 38 or whatever 100 but at
any rate it's it's a whole lot cheaper
than than what we're currently spending
for the questions from the committee
representative
thank you very much Mr chair so um
I think in in New Hampshire and these
numbers might be off a little bit but
there's about 15
New Hampshire students that attend
private schools and about another four
or five thousand New Hampshire students
that do home school
without a income cap and without annual
well without any without an income
um
cap on this any thoughts as to what the
yearly cost would be if if all these
students
take the voucher of
to you know help pay their tuition bills
but first off it's not a voucher a
voucher is a thing that is used then
I'll then I'll they'll just say um take
an EFA
I don't know how many I know that a lot
of the home schools will not
because they don't want any entanglement
with the government fair enough what
about for the 15 000 follow-up uh what
what about for the 15 000 students that
are in private schools
I don't know well I mean
that's the question I mean you can do
you can do the math if you're going to
assume that they all but I can't say
that they're all going to take it all
right so you can make whatever
assumptions you want would you believe
then that if all those students took it
you'd be talking north of 120 million
dollars a year if they all took it if
you did the math I believe your math
okay thanks for the questions from the
committee not seeing thank you very much
uh due to the number of cards I'm going
to do what we normally do we allow the
to sponsor the bill to have more time to
present uh but we're going to put a
limit of three minutes on each uh
speaker from this point forward
I'd like to recognize honor of
Campbell
I have a handout I'd like to hand out
so I've got three minutes so I'll try to
make it good I'm packing I've been here
before I used to serve in House
Education uh sponsored a bill a long
time ago called House Bill 603 that was
very similar in that the adequacy follow
the student and I think that's really
what we're talking about here today is
should the adequacy money follow the
student and I think it should
um but when it does I I don't think we
should do it at the detriment to our
local public schools and especially to
our local schools where there's poor
kids in those communities I would submit
to you that where we're going to see
efas if you want to ask the questions
are going to be in the school districts
that are struggling whether those are
the poor communities or communities that
maybe just don't have the best
reputation as an educational provider
those are probably where you're going to
see kids that are going to take
advantage of this program and I would
hope that all of us would agree that
that's a good thing that we should care
about all the kids in our state I will
point out that I think that um this bill
is fundamentally fair to lift the income
limit and I know representative made a
great point that we don't means test
people get the adequate education grant
that go to a government-run local school
or a municipal school
um but we do means to ask kids to get an
EFA so you have means testing for one
kid receiving an adequate education
grant and means test no means testing
for another kid those kids are similarly
situated and under our our sense of
fairness and dare I say our constitution
we have to treat people that are
similarly situated in a fair way I would
say right now we have a a constitutional
issue that we treat students differently
and that's not right we should fix that
but in order to fix that I think we have
to make the grand compromise so what
I've handed out is just a change to the
to go along with this bill the bill
would stay exactly the same way it's
written you know we're going to lift the
income limit but I would propose that
you would get rid of the term phase out
grants in the statute on 194 f
and that you would uh payments to
students residence districts so again
understanding education funding we pay
as a state for students in Residence and
that resonance to me is very important I
live in Farmington and I would say that
my local school district is the
heartbeat of our community we do a lot
of things around our school whether it's
Town meetings sporting events Gatherings
and I had a son who graduated from
Farmington High School and I had other
children that graduated from St Thomas
and I had you know as a child myself
went to both public and private schools
and I and I think we just got to respect
them equally and understand that that in
a free Society where you want diversity
you want to have these other educational
environments and because we haven't
funded those other educational
environments the Catholic School in my
community that was around for 110 years
closed this year
and if we don't change the way we're
funding it and we don't start funding
these opportunities for Education
equally we're going to see these really
powerful and good institutions continue
to close until we have just one option
and I would submit to you that we have
an oligarchy right now in that most
students a super majority 90 plus
percent are in government-run schools
and that's probably not healthy for our
freedom of thought and our stuff so I'm
asking both sides of the aisle to
consider what is there a compromise I
mean we all come to these committees and
we get elected for reasons and you all
have beliefs and there's nothing wrong
with that that's what we should do in a
free Society but sir we we have to look
at a compromise that says how can the
leader of One party and the leader of
another party come together and sponsor
an amendment and what I've handed out
specifically says that eligible students
represent package example you've got
honorable you've gone beyond your time
okay so you have in front of you the the
amendment and I just I would like to see
two thousand dollars go to the resident
school district for every student that
gets an EFA I I would like to see that
continue indefinitely so that the local
school district gets points uh gets
support if you if one side of the aisle
could increase funding for the adequate
education grant they would want to
this is the way you can do that and give
the other side of the aisle what they're
looking for thank you sir I appreciate
your questions for honorable Campbell
guess what represent Woodcock hey Cheryl
so let's understand this this two
thousand dollars will go back to the
sending School
yes my my proposal that I'm hoping
someone on this committee will make an
amendment would go back to the resident
District okay so the five thousand
dollars four thousand dollars whatever
it is goes to the EFA student's parents
and the state would provide an
additional 2 000 to the Sunday School to
replace that is that what you're saying
I read that correctly
correct so this would be additional
State funding that would go specifically
to the resident District it wouldn't be
out of the student's EFA money it would
be okay thank you thank you chairman
yeah further questions
thank you very much
representative
on your second page part three the esa
students will be eligible
and their residence School part-time and
participate in all extracurricular
activities and sports programs is that
meant to be at no additional cost yes
that's meant to be at no additional cost
So currently you you are allowed to do
that currently but the district can
charge you out of your EFA money to
attend that local school district and I
think that because my children are in
Residence and because I want the income
limit lifted it'd be consistent to list
the income limit but it'd be consistent
to say since I have a right to attend
there I'm not giving you the two
thousand dollars for nothing I'm saying
that you're going to provide services to
those students that are in Residence and
that just clarifies that that two grand
is for those students who want to attend
part-time maybe one AP class maybe
playing the basketball team and I think
that that's fair and I think that will
help communities like Farmington where
I'm from because we're probably going to
see a lot of kids that want to leave if
I was going to predict a district that
might lead in this category of students
that say oh my God have an opportunity
to go someplace else it might be a
Farmington or a Rochester so I really
hope that you'll consider this this what
I consider to be a grand compromise and
I'm asking all the stakeholders to
really give it serious consideration
reach out to me I'd be happy to to meet
with any of you I'd be happy to have a
quick subcommittee on this if that's
possible but I really think it's worth
considering a grand compromise because
given our our political climate that's
the only way we're going to get stuff
done just one last thought the pendulum
goes like this I don't want it to go way
over here or way over there I wanted to
just move a little bit and this is just
a little thing that we can do we can
argue about how much money does it save
or how much money does it cost I think
there's good arguments on both sides of
that but I do think it makes the most
sense and will save my community money
it will say Rochester money we won't
have to build hopefully more schools so
I hope that you'll give it consideration
and I really do appreciate all the hard
work you guys do I've come down here
four or five times this year and
different matters that I've gotten
involved in and I I really appreciate
all the time you spend and how much you
come down on snowy days so thank you all
thank you very much
thank you honorable camp
good morning I'm opposed to this bill
for several reasons first is the cost
estimate on the bill is is misleading
it's clear that it should start with a
baseline of 100 million dollars if the
20 000 people who currently are either
homeschooled or in private schools take
advantage of the five thousand dollar
voucher that's a baseline of 100 million
dollars second it assumes and just skims
over the whole subject of downshifting
of costs to local communities it's said
that oh it'll be cheaper for the towns
because we spend twenty thousand in the
public school and only five thousand for
this but if you lose ten percent of your
students in a public school you're not
going to really be able to save anything
off of your budget you still have your
fixed costs you're not going to fire any
teachers if you lose two students from
each classroom and you're certainly not
going to fire any paraprofessionals
because that's your special ed students
and any student that needs a
paraprofessional is not going to be
welcome in these private schools because
it would be way too expensive to pay
somebody thirty thousand dollars a year
as a para to work with somebody in
special right so this is a huge economic
cost that's not adequately stated in the
bills as it's presented second this bill
will result in the hollowing out of our
local schools because they will lose
money they will not be able to keep up
with what they're doing they're going to
have to cut worthwhile programs that
hundred million dollars could be spent
to do what we were told to do in
Claremont decision and we've heard about
adequate education spend it on the poor
schools that need that money now it
would make a difference in fact I'll
read you one little study here this is a
review of 13 studies of whether or not
money makes any difference in schools
and they said it does make a difference
in Wisconsin they found that 600 dollars
per student especially in low-income
districts led to a reduction in the
dropout rate by 25 percent in schools
getting proficient scores up five to ten
percent in Texas they found that a
thousand dollars more reduced Dropout
rates in college enrollment went up nine
percent and there's quite a bit more
studies that I don't have time with only
three minutes to give you but the point
is that money he would be better spent
in our local schools right now that's
the obligation we have under Claremont
the next issue was well does this
actually increase education for people
the studies around the country have
found that vouchers reduce educational
results for the students who leave a
public school and go to the private
school Diane ravich talks about a study
of those 20 years worth of results from
Professor Cowan large-scale independent
studies in DC Indiana Louisiana Ohio
show that for kids who left Public
Schools harmful voucher impacts actually
meet or exceed what the pandemic did to
test scores meaning that you lose over a
third of the year of school by the time
you're done being in the voucher
programs vouchers do not work you end up
getting even worse results lastly I'm
opposed to this bill because it's
discriminatory we hear about parents
rights there is no parent right if you
don't fit into the special categories
that of people who can access the
voucher bills if your child has a
disability you're really not going to be
welcome in the private schools look at
the voucher plans six percent of the
students are special ed versus eighteen
percent in the public schools that's it
is that my time well okay I'll just
finish by saying I have there's many
groups of people who are not going to be
eligible to participate but certainly
special ed students you have a 300
difference between the private schools
in the special education schools I have
uh testimony I'll submit that to you
tonight by email thank you very much uh
any questions for Mr Trimble
reps in cordelli uh thank you just on
your discrimination comments
um uh do you know if there are any
um students with special needs who are
participating in the EFA program yeah
the statistics say that six percent of
the students in the FEA program are
considered special education in the
public schools that number is 18 that's
a 300 percent difference the other thing
that's that my comment is about in
specific is this is that if you have a
child who has a complex special
education issue or is going to be
expensive that child has to be educated
in the public schools the public schools
educate every single child regardless of
expense but in the private school
they're not going to take a child who's
going to cost them thirty thousand
dollars a year to have a one-on-one
paraprofessional because that's in
excess of the total tuition amount so
it's it's not if you want the argument
has been made today it's not fair to
keep our money away from the private
schools in the religious schools if you
want it to be fair and equal then the
private and the religious schools should
agree to abide by all of the state
regulations no discrimination on the
basis of 193.38 and they should agree to
give every student who applies a free
and appropriate education
follow up thank you so then for those
private schools for instance that
maybe cannot accommodate all students
should the state provide them funny
funding so they can accommodate those
students like they do with Public
Schools then basically you're turning
that into a public school and if that's
what you want to do then I would say we
heard friendly amendments I would
propose friendly amendments to this bill
that the charter I mean at the private
schools would agree to educational
accountability that they would agree to
abide by 193.38 no discrimination for
any reason they would agree to special
education and they will begin you would
also make sure that you don't have an
adverse effect on the local schools with
downshifting if you're willing to make
religious schools say I will only take
EFA money if I I will agree to no
discrimination special education and
educational accountability then let's
see which schools sign up for this plan
further questions represent McDonald
thank you Mr chair thank you for your
testimony once again
um with all due respect could you please
direct me to a point in this bill or
within the EFA chapter where the word
voucher is used because to my
understanding the word voucher does not
appear in the EFA RSA and therefore the
statistics you cited about voucher plans
across the country would not apply to
New Hampshire so could you just clarify
that please okay I I understand that
this state is what we're calling it an
education Freedom account in Indiana
they use something similar uh I'm sorry
education savings account uh it was
called the Indiana Choice legislation
the terms are slightly different in in
different states and the emphasis is now
become
to emphasize the word choice because the
the policy argument that it was help
education was proven to not be effective
so therefore we switched over to the
argument of choice for parents so we
call them Freedom or Choice accounts but
the the educational system basically
where the government says to a parent
we'll give you this amount of money you
go find a private school that you want
to send your child to and we'll pay for
it that basic formula applies whether
it's called a voucher in in District of
Columbia or Louisiana or whether it's
called a choice legislation in Indiana
or it's called an education Freedom
account in New Hampshire the function is
basically the same
thank you you're welcome further
are you aware that the
um the way an EFA Works in New Hampshire
is very different from just giving you
some money to go to another school that
it can be used for a wide variety of
things tutoring books
um and a a complex system where you get
some classes here some classes there
what works for a student which is quite
different than
here's some money go find a different
school I'm sorry I didn't really speak
completely when I answered that question
I was just trying to explain that the
research on vouchers is relevant to New
Hampshire but if you look at the other
states they end up as these programs
have evolved they're not that much
different from what you're describing
for New Hampshire it's not just I
shouldn't have said here's money go to a
private school that was kind of the the
original decades ago when they first
started but in all these states it's
evolved to a multitude of different ways
to spend that money so I think what
we're doing here under the EFA plan is
not dramatically different than what's
been tried in other states
further questions
representative Bruno thank you very much
Mr chair and this is a follow-up sort of
to representative Lucas's um uh question
and um and you know and I think I I I
know I agree with with you in using the
term voucher because I think that
generically applies across the board to
these types of similar programs you know
in um uh in other states but um but
unlike some other states are you aware
that as as representative ligas
suggested that that New Hampshire
actually has a kitchen sink clause and
it's um in the in the voucher
um uh statue which essentially allows
the uh the uh the contractor to approve
any um any expense it um it deems fit I
see what you're saying so that this the
family can use it to expand their
internet at home or to buy a computer
for their child or you can I think
become even more more imaginative on on
on expenses too but but but it's called
a kitchen a kitchen sink Clause right I
mean it but the thing is that if your
family can afford to use the five
thousand dollars for that
and still attend a private school then
you're in a situation where you're
financially successful enough to be able
to do that but this five thousand
dollars won't if you if you can't afford
to do that and you have to use every
penny to pay tuition to a private school
you're not going to be able to do it
unless you're of a certain level means
the the average price of
tuition in private schools in New
Hampshire for elementary schools is 11
000 and for high schools is nineteen
thousand so even if you get five
thousand off of that at high school
level you're talking fourteen thousand
more dollars if you have two children
that's twenty eight thousand dollars a
year on top of your regular expenses
this plan I was trying to get to
discrimination on income as well as
special ed but on income if you don't
have twenty eight thousand dollars extra
in income you can't really meaningfully
participate in this program so you have
parental rights for those who don't who
have a child who doesn't have a
significant special education need and
if you have enough income you can
participate but a lot of people would be
thanks so so I I agree with with all of
that in terms of the the additional
tuition costs and and participation
where you can where you can afford it
but um but is is there actually a
requirement that that you have that you
have to attend school at all
um uh in the in the compulsory
attendance uh requirements can uh I
don't honestly know I mean I think you
can do homeschooling in which case you
have to submit a plan
um but right but but but isn't it true
though that the that the EFA EFA program
yeah follow-up thank you Mr chair isn't
it true that the EFA program has a has
um basically waives the compulsory
attendance requirement and that simply
having an EFA satisfies the compulsory
attendance requirement I'm not qualified
to answer I think somebody from the doe
would be better in qualified for that
one I'm not going to take any more
questions right now at this uh
particular uh person testifying Mr
Trimble thank you very much thank you Mr
good morning and thank you for helping
me speak this morning my name is Serena
Varley and I live in Concord I have
seven kids
um
and
we have been working on educating all of
them we have done many different things
over the years we've done public school
private school home school
and I am here in support of this bill I
think in order to provide an adequate
education for all New Hampshire students
we should offer education free Freedom
accounts to every child in New Hampshire
um and remove the cap
uh just to give you a little background
I grew up in Vermont and was and
benefited from what was essentially an
education Freedom account I went to a
private school
and actually went to Dartmouth College
afterwards and I think without the
ability to do that Vermont traditionally
offered this kind of program for about
over 100 years and without that
opportunity I don't think I would have
been able to succeed like I did
educationally I think New Hampshire has
um
an interest in giving an adequate good
education to every New Hampshire student
and that it should not be
mean space at all
and
um
I think that um
going back to what Mr Trimble said I I
disagree with him because I think the
purpose of an educational Freedom
account was for the success of students
and not for the success of schools and
that anything that we can do as a state
to support students we should do and not
have a means tip means test
the other thing I wanted to mention is
that we have
um
like somebody else mentioned we have all
we all pay taxes we've paid taxes all
these you know for we've lived in
Concord for over 20 years we've paid
taxes and we
um
we think that that it's only right that
as a New Hampshire taxpayers we should
be able to
um benefit just like every other student
in every other family in New Hampshire
can and have the same opportunities that
every other New Hampshire
student has to education
thank you very much are there any
questions from the committee represent
Woodcock thank you chairman good morning
when you introduce yourself you talk
about some youngsters who have
participated in public and private
parochial on efas do you have any
youngsters currently now in the involved
with the EFA account no we do not we are
um
outside the
300 okay limit okay thank you thank you
chair welcome further questions from the
committee
thank you very much okay thank you uh
thanks for having me Kate Baker Demers I
run the current EFA program and so I
came today
um to answer any questions that anyone
has about what this might look like I
also um have the opportunity to answer
the telephone at Children's scholarship
fund and I spoke to a family last week
who is a widowed woman with one child
and she asked me unfortunately what are
the income limits on the program her
income is 59 000 and the income is 54
000 and she's hoping that her son can
participate in a hybrid program and she
doesn't know how she's going to pay for
the hybrid program and so I would just
encourage you to consider any move
towards increasing the income limits or
removing the income limits because there
are families that have need and they do
contact us you know not overwhelmingly
so I don't know again what the what it
would look like if that existed but I do
know that anytime you put an income
limit on something you've got people
that are one or two dollars over there
was just a couple of things I heard
earlier in this discussion there's been
a lot of talk about dollars and costs
and I understand that you know this is a
policy committee not the finance
committee but you still end up getting
stuck on that a lot and I would just
encourage you to consider that children
are not funding units
but rather humans and children and so
when you're thinking about funding
children I I understand you tend to get
caught up on that cost issue but in fact
you know they're not funding units to be
assigned in essence by or where we think
they should go but rather children
trying to get educated and their parents
you know know them best and so I would
just encourage that the other thing I
heard again was to talk about special
education today and about 51 of our out
of District placement schools in New
Hampshire for special ed kids with
extreme special needs are private
schools and so I just wanted to throw
that out there in addition the
discussion about discrimination you know
when I walk up to the door of a public
school my kids also attended public
school they didn't ask me if I was 300
percent of the poverty limit or below to
go there they just said you're welcome
to come and so I do think that again
children are not funding units there are
quite a few family these that have
distinct need who fall one or two
dollars over the income limits we have
now and I definitely support this this
discussion support this idea of of
increasing or removing the income limits
from the program thank you very much are
there questions from the community
representative parano
thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question there was a
comment earlier about
um
education Freedom account funds being
used for internet but I'm looking
through your vendor list and I'm not
seeing any internet so in the rules the
department of Ed said had to be 51 for
the child and so what you can do is get
a hot spot it's not as effective as as
covering the cost of household internet
but because the rules defined it as
the internet cost has to be 51 used by
the child it's impossible to pay for
household internet it has to be a hot
spot I mean I I don't I think you should
be able to use it for internet because
again when this bill was passed it was
in the midst of the pandemic and the
shutdown and there were families who
didn't have technology a computer
internet or access to it and I think
that's why the legislators put it in the
bill so that families could have access
to computers technology tutors when
otherwise their school was closed and in
essence though when they passed the
rules they narrowed it so that's why
you're seeing that
representative uh Damon
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question yeah you're welcome
it's puzzling to me that the current EFA
program does not appear to have anywhere
near the same accountability or
measurement of outcomes proficiencies as
the public school systems are required
to do could you speak to why we would
fund more students into a program
without that so I do think that taking a
standardized test is similar So a family
in the EFA program has to take a
standardized test and turn it in that is
similar to what they do in the public
schools where students are required to
take the Statewide assessment and so I
don't see very much difference at all in
that regard
thank you quick follow-up
where is the data on those outcomes the
test scores are aggregated and then that
data is given to the Department of Ed
further questions representative Myler
uh thank you Mr chair and thank you for
being here yeah you're welcome I mean
obviously the the person is here hi
representative
um nice to see you children's
scholarship fund so here's a question
for you okay great that's been in the
back of my mind
it's my understanding that uh vouchers
can be utilized by a public school
student going to another public school
student a school is that correct yes
although again a voucher would be the
department of Ed paying a private school
the education Freedom account you know
the philosophy is going into the parent
account and I you know I don't I don't
need to get into that but in essence the
parent is directing the money and yes
they can direct that money to pay a
public school for classes courses when
there are some kids full-time as a
follow-up yeah so my child happens to be
a special education child yeah the
special education services
so if my child moves from school
district Public School District a to
public school district B and needs those
sped Services who is responsible for
providing those sped services so it
looks like there's a student just like
this in our program and it looks like
the district that they move to is giving
them Services well it's not the resident
School District correct the resident
District
um has that you know because they know
they're in a different district and so
it seems like the different district is
providing those Services I think also
that the department of Ed or the State
Board of Ed put that in the rules that
if you move to a different school with
an IEP your IEP continues in the school
the family is paying the district from
the education Freedom account so the Pat
the family's paying for it it looks like
and this is uh this is an important
distinction thank you and uh thanks for
this clarification no problem but I
don't mind if if the uh services
are more than what the vouchers paying
for
who pays for the balance
of that in this particular student's
case the parent is paying additional
money plus the scholarship plus the
education Freedom account to cover the
cost this is this they're paying for the
extra special education service I don't
know they call it tuition at the
district
further questions
representative Allison did that help
representative Milan okay okay thank you
Mr chair thank you for taking my
question okay uh you started with an
example of a a family a woman and a
child around 59 000. uh
is it your belief that a family that has
an income of two hundred thousand
dollars a year should be eligible for an
EFA I mean I'm going to go out on wild
limb and tell you yes because if I had
an income of two hundred thousand
dollars I could enroll in a neighborhood
public school and they wouldn't tell me
to pay I mean in essence you know if you
believe in funding the child which I do
and think that every child should have
you know the freedom to choose whichever
building works for them or in the case
of a medically fragile child during
covid that couldn't go into a building
I'm also for that child being able to be
educated outside of a building and in
essence for the money to follow the
child I don't think it should be litmus
test by any income level follow up yes
uh
taking a step forward further if this
family earns three quarters of a million
dollars or should they be yellow Jewel
for an EFA I think so yes thank you yeah
I'm going to say there aren't very many
people in New Hampshire in the income
bracket the other thing I noticed is
that you know the families do have to
jump through a bunch of Hoops to be in
this program and
um extremely affluent people don't need
to jump through our Hoops they're just
going to do what they want to do anyway
you know in essence families in that
income bracket have always had school
choice and always will have school
choice because they can send their kids
to whatever school they want to go to
and so I feel like the likelihood of
them jumping through my you know Hoops
would be low and or I would agree that
every child should be have their
education funding representative dry
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question you're welcome uh do
any of the non-public schools that
accept efa's have means tests of their
own for students
so you're saying non-public schools so
you're asking about private schools I
mean many of them do have some internal
financial aid but there aren't any that
are specifically for a particular income
group does that answer the question like
all the schools are open to all children
uh follow up please yes all right I
actually want my question would be
um that
I do know for example if you go to St
Paul's and you earn
um 80 000 or below you get a full
scholarship
okay so is that how let's speak to maybe
that is 80 000 and above they would not
be eligible for scholarships it's there
would that be something that might uh
open it up to everybody but may if
you've applied according to
um the means for that particular school
with that maybe make it open to everyone
but not necessarily
um make it
applicable to you know to people who
don't need the money yeah I don't think
people that don't need the money are
going to come and do all of the work
associated with it but I do think that
there are a lot of people or rather a
group of people in that gap of
middle-income families you know
particularly since the economy is so
difficult it seems like I'm hearing from
more families that are just slightly
over the income limit discussing what
they wish they could do but they can't
do or discussing need that they may have
and so I just feel like
in essence when we talk about this
adequate education grant I agree with
you know earlier that it's for
every child in the state and so I don't
think limiting it by a particular
demographic really makes sense thank you
represent Woodcock thank you chairman uh
how are you well we'll know what I mean
I guess yeah nice to see you uh I want
to follow up with President Milo's
question I I think I just want to be
sure I hear what you said but correctly
I wrote it down but I'm not sure hero
correctly I think his question was if a
student in public school a special
education student yeah takes a a voucher
or if anyone who takes the opportunity
it goes to public school B yeah doesn't
reside there because I think the words
you use move to but I'm in public school
a yeah I decide to go to have my
youngster go to public school B and they
have special education services
requirements that are extraordinary
right okay who is which public school is
responsible for paying those
so the parent is paying the cost at the
school
so so I I'm having a difficult time I
think understanding where you're going
with the questions well yeah because in
this case this families are paying the
school tuition
and so in my experience whether a child
with special needs goes to a private
school or a public school
the tuition doesn't necessarily change
and so when a child goes to a private
school and they have special needs the
private school still charges the tuition
that they charge and at a public school
they're doing the same thing so they're
just charging their family their tuition
that's just to clarify I wasn't talking
about tuition I'm talking about the
expensive especially saving expense for
that youngster if you look at it public
school is uh twenty seven thousand
dollars sure any movies any move to
public school would be because they like
they like that public school yeah I mean
travels there it doesn't live there yeah
so it's public school be paying the 29
000 for that service or is public school
a where he came from I don't I guess I
don't I don't know because the parent is
paying what the school tells them to pay
so the school says the cost to come here
is X is it probably 20 000 and then the
parent pays the tuition I think the
school considers that comprehensive of
every service they provide usually thank
you does that help no but thank you oh
okay am I missing something you guys
representative vladim I missing
I think with that same question is going
to go over and over and over some people
are going to see resolution to it others
are not okay um I'm just wondering am I
missing the point of it you might not
answer enough no okay thank you for uh
for taking my question it was brought up
um the idea of somebody with a three and
a half million dollar income possibly
using this program obviously some
concern that they would be unnecessarily
taking from this program we obviously
don't use income as our funding
mechanism in this state we use property
um so let's substitute 3.5 million for
property can you imagine how or estimate
how many EFA programs a person with a
3.5 million dollar property you paying
taxes on it might be funding in this
state of course it depends on the town
right and so if you're in a low tax town
like Newberry right you might be paying
for what 200 kids efas and if you're in
a in a all right lower well if your
property tax is higher you'd be paying
for more kids if your property tax is
lower although you know what I gotta
just pull you aside because this money
is just State money your swept stays
local and you're so in essence a
property taxpayer isn't paying for any
of these kids because your swept is
local and a credit okay so your swept
stays in your town as a credit against
money that your the state would pay and
you all your property tax stays local
and so I gotta correct you a property
taxpayer in any Town wouldn't pay for
any of these children the money for
these children comes from the general
fund which moves into the education
trust fund and the general fund is
funded by business taxes business
Enterprise tax meals and rooms tax real
estate those kinds of taxes and so I I
there you go that's fair thing okay
you're welcome I'd like to just caution
the committee here I'm very way off top
topic where yes we went way off the
topic here and we need to hold to the
policies associated with
lifting the cap
when we get into a specific taxes and
swept and finances leave it for fiscal
later please if there is another
committee with that responsibility
further questions
representative balbooni
please thank you chairman thank you for
taking my question you said earlier in
response to another question that the
any child could attend any school with
an EFA but don't certain private schools
religious schools have admission
requirements
so at this point because student
population is declining by so much I'm
finding schools recruiting you might see
weird admissions requirements in some of
the more like St Paul's type schools but
in your everyday little low-cost private
schools they're accepting everyone that
comes and recruiting and trying to get
more kids and so I understand you're
thinking maybe about Merit like St
Paul's or Phillips Exeter those schools
are always going to have those types of
Niche markets but they also don't need a
family's money from an education Freedom
account because they have their own
endowments so follow up
sorry follow up to that one okay say you
had a Saint Paul's and everything are
the kids right now that have efas using
them at St Paul's there aren't
no
thank you you're welcome represent
McDonald thank you Mr chair thank you
for taking my question a number was
thrown out earlier of a hundred million
dollars of all private and homeschoolers
applied that would be the cost of this
okay but you said that there is an
extensive process to apply and therefore
people who really do not need this um to
fund their child's education would not
so therefore could we assume that the
price tag would actually be less if this
bill were to pass
I mean again there isn't any real way to
project you can look at what's happened
in other states in programs where they
have no income limits and they see the
uptake at like five percent of the
general population so if you think about
it this way I mean 95 of the kids in New
Hampshire attend a public school right
and about five percent do something
different I don't know why we would
expect that trajectory to change because
you make more opportunities most of the
families that come to us are you know
kids that experience bullying
our special needs children who feel like
their needs are not being met in the
public school they want to opt out and
do something totally different maybe pay
for their services kids that are below
grade level significantly and the family
feels like they need a smaller class
size we also hear from children who are
significantly above grade level and they
feel like they need to do something
different
in essence that's where most of the
families come from and so it's
reasonable to think it will be a certain
percentage of the population that
chooses it but most people that I talk
to are happy with their local public
school and would probably stay there as
a matter of fact we see children come to
us sometimes for a smaller Elementary
School experience and then go to their
local public high school because that's
what they want to do we also see
families in this program choosing to go
to public school with with some of the
education Freedom account money and use
it so to me I always see it as a both
and it seems like your discussions on
this committee tend to be very either or
where you're thinking that this program
is the opposite of attending a public
school and so in your mind you're asking
yourself how many kids would leave a
public school and in essence perhaps you
should be asking yourself how many
people might choose to go instead to a
public school with this money for for a
specialized program I I don't know that
either or it doesn't necessarily make
sense when the program is both and that
helps a lot thank you for other
questions represent Hall thank you Mr
chair thank you for being here and
taking my question so just a quick
question do you believe that all
students will receive public money
should be held to the same standards and
regulations so I don't know what you
mean by that question because I know for
example
um there was a district where there were
children scoring at like 20 percent
proficient meaning to me that like 80
percent of the kids were not at grade
level and so I don't know what what
standard you would want to apply to them
to say if that should apply to everyone
so I don't think we have a universal
standard you know my one of my children
went to high school in in Bedford New
Hampshire and that school is a high
performing school where the standards
are are high and everyone's test scores
are high are would you want to apply
that standard to everyone in the state
or would you want to take a a struggling
District where for example the children
are you know speak a thousand languages
and are our free reduced lunch I mean
those kids I don't want to say they
should have a different standard but in
essence I I don't I don't know what
standard we would apply to all children
equally to be able to make it make sense
I guess great well I would actually
think okay say State testing for example
the state test what I say I mean I like
the idea in the education Freedom
account where the family takes a
standardized test of their choice or can
have a portfolio evaluation I feel like
particularly for children with special
needs or if you have a child who um
isn't for example is an English language
learner perhaps they would want to use
the portfolio evaluation have their
portfolio evaluated by someone who
speaks their language and so I like the
diversity in that the family can say
this is the assessment that we think
works for our child I think that's good
in essence I trust families and it this
program trusts families to say that they
should be in in the driver's seat and so
I think if the parent says this is what
is the right thing for my child then we
should support that and I think that's
more important accountability if the
family doesn't feel like this is working
for them they'll leave and they'll go do
something else you know similarly to you
know how a charter school works if it's
not performing well the families will
leave and not go to that charter school
and it will close and so I feel like
that's good good accountability or
rather authentic accountability
okay further questions representative
cardelli
and thank you Mr chairman thank you uh
for being here
um in terms of other states that have a
universal education savings accounts
yeah
um I think West Virginia is up and
running
um this year for the first year it took
them a year to get up and running for
some reason
um do you have any idea the number of
students who have signed up in West
Virginia for those accounts and what
percentage that might be well that's a
good question so I do know how many I
know they started with their opening
group was 1600 and then they got to 3
000 and again the West Virginia program
has no income limits on it and so that's
representative cordelli's question is
what does a program look like when there
are no income limits they have twice the
population of us per you know so we have
a million people in our state and they
have about 2 million and again they were
at sixteen hundred and three thousand so
their program actually is the same size
as ours even with no income limits
further questions represent luno thank
you very much Mr chair to the um to the
comment you made um just a few moments
ago with respect to authentic
accountability and uh parents who who
pull their children out of their public
school to to go to that I mean that it
it it seems like we're ignoring the 800
pound gorilla of the approximately 3 200
students in the program maybe there's
only about a hundred where where parents
made an affirmative decision to leave
their Public Schools so that the the um
you know remarks that we heard from
from former member Campbell and and your
early remarks with respect to uh to
students actually exiting their Public
School really does seem like the
minority because of the 3200 at least
like 3 100 were either already in
um private schools or home schools are
going to go to private or home schools
anyway so so when when when you look at
income eligibility and I want to get it
back to the to the point of this bill
um uh I'm I'm I'm looking looking
through what where where these students
are currently going uh prior to taking
the um the uh joining the EFA program
um how how relevant is the income
eligibility to uh to school choice
I don't understand the question
with 3 100 students either already go
into private school or home school or
going to go to private or home school
anyway only about a hundred students
actually making a decision to leave
their public school and and go to uh go
to a private school and
um uh so so for the program as a whole
where most of these students already in
you know private or home school
environments are going to go anyway how
relevant is the income eligibility or
lack thereof
um in this to um uh to uh to school
choice okay I understand the question
now
um so again I see this as a both and not
in either or and so you're definitely on
the either or team representative Luna
where you're looking at it as a child
doing it
go for words in my mouth okay sorry just
talk about what what what you believe
okay the opportunity that's created by
lifting the cap and how that applies to
the the 100 students ish that make an
affirmative decision to leave public
school because of the voucher and the
approximately 3 100 students
um ish that were already in private or
home school environments or going to go
that way anyway family history of doing
that what you know what whatever their
reasons so so I'm just trying to
understand where how the how the lifting
of the calf so getting back to the core
of this bill how that applies to the
majority students who are already in
non-public school options versus the
very small percentage that are in public
school and um and how that income
lifting the income cap
um
how that matters to these these two
different
um groups great happy to answer your
question thank you so much for the
question
um again I do see this as a both and and
so of the 3200 children that are
currently in the program the department
of Ed's calculation was that 42 percent
of them had been in public school at
some point
um and then also there's a group of
children to your point in that 3200 and
we are choosing to go to a public school
with the EFA dollars in that group of
families the 3200
um there were 337 families that were
over the income limit and so I know that
in discussing the income limits and
removing them or increasing them it
would provide opportunity to those 337
families who applied who were over the
income limits
um I think that answers the question yes
um just I'm I'm willing to let it go
okay questions
thank you very much oh you're welcome uh
uh chairman she she had to leave and she
passed around I didn't know she left
uh Sarah Scott
same thing she just walked out the door
she will submit testimony okay
um
at wchr
um w-e-h-r okay and my handwriting is
bad
um so um
uh my name is Jenny landra um I have
three children
um and uh as we're having children my
husband and I um we're constantly
talking that schools are our biggest
concern for our children
um education is extremely important to
us
um and once we moved
um we moved to a local public school
because of their school ratings or
public school ratings
um and once we started our oldest
daughter into the public school
um we were shocked with how little Focus
was on academics
um we were shocked at how kids were
already bullying and being bullied in
the first grade
um our daughter would come home and tell
us about
um all the bullying and having to like
kids would schedule time for each other
recess
um and how if one child acts out in the
class the teacher spends all of her time
dealing with that child and takes away
from the rest of the class so she was in
a first grade class of like 20 to 22
kids and so she was just getting lost
our daughter was bullied she was shy
it just wasn't working so um we were
shocked and we decided to pull our kids
out of the local schools uh the local
public schools and I was extremely
shocked as to how few people asked why
even the principal who I worked with
monthly and others when told
um said I understand I think school
choice is the only answer to this
problem if people get to take their
money with their child to whatever
School works best for them then this
will force the public schools to step up
their game there's currently no
incentive or competition to be better
and most people can't afford what we've
done and it's sad that they can't and we
are right above the income threshold so
we aren't able to take advantage
um
of any money and I just don't think that
that's fair and I know people that are
in the same boat and the kid just can't
afford it they can't afford especially
when we have three kids it's a lot of
money
um
so let's see
um I think allowing parents to put their
children in the best situation for their
child should be everyone's top priority
children are our future
um and this is what our tax dollars are
meant for why should a child be stuck
bullied every day with no hope of a
brighter future why should a child that
thrives in education be stuck being
bored in public schools because they
require kids to stay at the same level
unless they decide differently why
should the parent have to watch their
child go into a classroom hide in the
corner because they're shy and the
teacher can't manage the large amount of
kids
I think school choice is the best for
everyone and I don't think that there
should be a cap on how much you make
thank you very much are there any
questions representative
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
um it seems to me that
you would actually prefer to have your
child in the public school if the
circumstances were different but because
of what you experienced there
you pulled your child out and you're if
I'm hearing correctly you think there
are other families that might be in that
situation who would be willing to take
advantage of the education Freedom
accounts correct to protect their
children yeah so I mean uh just a long
story
um my husband and I actually lived um on
the west coast and the schools were
there over there were terrible and so
when our children were getting to the
age where they were going to come to
Public Schools we then reached out and
we looked in New Hampshire and
Massachusetts are one of the top schools
in the country and so that's why we
moved to New Hampshire so we moved here
to go to the public schools we were both
kind of against private schools just
because we wanted our kids to know the
local kids and and things like that but
then it just wasn't a good fit for our
kids
yeah further questions
good morning everybody thank you for the
time uh Peter Serrato
um I live in Bedford we moved there a
few years ago I have on a 11 and 13 year
old in the public schools so um I'm
right in the throes of it if you will
um we moved to Bedford for the schools
primarily we moved from Massachusetts
um
and we are seriously considering moving
our kids from the public schools and I'm
more of a data real world example type
of person so you know everyone's touched
on most of the topics but um
so people believe Bedford schools are
one of the best in New Hampshire right I
think we're a top five if um not
mistaken but did you know that our math
proficiency proficiency at the high
school 41 of the kids are below grade
level 41 that's almost half
we don't even have spelling words in
Bedford my kids have been in Bedford
since fourth grade we have no spelling
words no just not part of the curriculum
unbelievably so
um you know at 20 000 per year I believe
is what you said each student is no
spelling words how are the kids going to
be able to spell well they can't
um I was going through some other local
schools like Manchester Central High
School 70 of the kids are below
Proficiency in math 70 percent
58 for ELA 42 in math
um we're at
a level one meaning I don't know they
just put their name on the test
you know they're not even close to
proficiency
we've got Nashua High School South 63
are below proficiency math 40 below in
the UI
Londonderry 58 Below in math
um 33 in ela I mean these are these are
disgraceful numbers
like I assume everyone's goal here is to
make sure our kids get the best
education they can is there any
accountability in these Public Schools
really they've already got our money you
know I've
um in fifth grade I asked for my sons
the curriculum I said could I please
have the approved curriculum
and to my surprise he said what do you
mean by approved and I was like what do
you mean like the approved curriculum I
couldn't get it they would not give it
to me they sent me a list of like 20
books from the Wonders Ela program
and that's just academics
if you want to get into like the real
nitty-gritty
um last year we've been noticing a lot
of I would say inappropriate books and
materials in the school of particularly
the library so this book Lawn Boy I
don't know if anyone's familiar with it
um you know it has depictions of 10 year
olds giving each other's oral sex
um
the word you know the way the f word is
97 times the word asked 20 times 60
times no not exactly a literary piece so
one parent just um asked to have it
removed from the library because it's
inappropriate which I wholeheartedly
agree with
so there was a this whole big long
process they put together a panel the
panel approved it superintendent said it
was great and the school board said it
was great we can't get out of the school
so basically you can't get any book out
of the school they can order from Amazon
any sexually explicit book no problem
they're not going to pull it out so what
am I supposed to do as a parent
like we're we're trying to figure out
how financially we're going to afford to
send our kids to private school wrap it
up please yes I will
um I was on the library last night
and this book isn't enough
in the library handmaid's tale it's the
Hulu show if anyone knows it's ready to
mature this is a graphic novel
you know it's got pictures of like girls
being raped
this picture
of this old guy he's pulling up his
pants after you raped the girl this is
for 14 year olds at our school
so what am I supposed to do as a parent
here
like we things need to change this is
not acceptable the schools are not
accountable they already have our money
you know efas are they the primary
solution I think it's a big step in the
right direction and this is just a state
money even if you've got to wrap it up
please all right I'm sorry
um so I wholeheartedly support this if
anyone has any questions
feel free to take them thank you very
much are there questions from the
committee representative Balboni
so Sharon thank you for taking my
question I saw that you pulled up a lot
of statistics on proficiency numbers and
everything and these were all from
public schools in your research are you
able to find any um comparable
statistics for the private schools of
New Hampshire or the religious schools
um I didn't look that up honestly
thank you further questions from the
committee not seeing you thank you very
foreign
good morning chairman LED members of the
committee I am pleased to be here to
address you this morning on HB 331 I'm
going to try not to repeat uh all that's
been said already about this proposal to
remove the income caps on the state's
Voucher Program
but I will reflect a little bit on some
things I have heard I've heard that this
should be about the students and um oh
by the way just to back up a little bit
I am the President of the American
Federation of teachers New Hampshire and
I represent about 4 000 members who work
in K-12 schools across the state as well
as in public universities and in public
service and among us we work with about
29 000 of the 165 000 public school
students across the state and apparently
should be about students and what they
need and I want to say that every single
public school student in the state
should have those small class sizes that
we heard
um a previous speaker talking about so
they can get the individual attention
from a teacher
or the learning support from a para
educator to get exactly what they need
so they can do their best learning
and in order to do that we need the
people in this building
or in the building across the street
to fulfill their constitutional Duty
to provide an adequate public education
because that's what's in the New
Hampshire Constitution you have to
provide it you have to fund it and I
know you've got a lot of bills in front
of you this year trying once again to
solve that problem this bill doesn't get
you any closer to it
your constitutional duty is to a public
education parents can make other choices
they certainly have every right to do
that
but
you do not have a constitutional
obligation to fund that
and when the legislature two years ago
passed
passed a law
creating the voucher program
obligation that is being contested in
court
this will increase that funding
obligation without making the legality
of it any clearer
so you need to keep that in mind and as
we've heard there are 15 000 students
sixteen thousand students in public
school plus another you know five
thousand or so that could take advantage
of this
if the income limits are removed from
the voucher program so that is a big
obligation even though we are supposed
to keep policy separate from Finance you
can't do that because the money does
come from the taxpayers
and it's got to come from somewhere
there's no Magic Money Tree but just
imagine you are a single mother in
Hudson
you are paying your mortgage your bills
your taxes because your taxes do indeed
fund the public schools you've gone
beyond three minutes okay I will wrap it
up you like that your students are going
to Auburn High School and they are
getting their AP U.S history they are
also able to take carpentry at the CTE
program there but now your taxes are
going up because you are going to fund
you know someone sending their kid to
Phillips Exeter
and what do you do do you sell your home
and move
this is not fair it's a giveaway thank
you very much do you have written
testimony it's coming around
uh do you care take any questions
I will entertain questions I don't know
if I'll have the answers but I will talk
representative cordelli yes uh thank you
thank you for uh testifying but I just
wanted to clarify for transparency
purposes am I correct that you currently
have an active lawsuit against the
commissioner in this program I do yes
over the mechanism for funding the
program thank you it should not come out
of the education trust fund that is for
public education
further questions represent Belcher
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question I just wanted to
clarify the position
um what do you would you suggest that
students using the EFA program either in
public I'm sorry either in a private or
home school environment are not
is to provide
an adequate public education I am not
saying anything about the adequacy of
other forms of Education okay so I I
would suggest that that was not an
accurate summary of what I said
now further questions
thank you very much I'd like to invite
thank you Mr chair and members of the
committee I'm Mary Wilke I'm from
Concord um and I oppose HB 331
am I I saw somebody looking forward can
you hear me
okay thanks
um
as others have alluded to the vast
majority of people who have taken efas
so far had students who were already in
private or home school without using
afas that wasn't the premise under which
the EFA program was sold to was sold in
the first place
and go back to 2017 when SB 93 was under
consideration and then right up through
2021 when the current program was
adopted
opponents consistently made the argument
that the program was needed for kids who
did not fit in the public school or
whose needs were not being met there
the people who came to testify in favor
of the program were parents were mostly
parents of children who were in public
school or had recently been in public
school and were having problems there or
had special needs that weren't being met
in the parents opinion he didn't hear
sponsors of the program saying that it
was needed to help private schools by
substituting State scholarships for the
scholarships the private schools were
already giving
we didn't hear sponsors saying that efas
were needed to help wealthy parents
continue to send those to their children
to private schools or to help children I
mean excuse me to help parents who have
access to a public school that would
meet all the academic needs of their
children but wanted instead of religious
education and wanted the state to pick
up the tab
but that's what's happened and about 80
percent of efas have gone to families
that were already in private or home
school without any help from the state
the majority of them apparently from
what I can tell from the doe records
have never tried public school so the
program has strayed far from the course
of its original intent and eliminating
the financial eligibility requirement
would make it straight even farther
others have talked about how many
students are currently in private and
home schools and how if they all took in
the fa that would end up costing the
state somewhere in the neighborhood of
100 million dollars a year
others say that they won't all take it
if they won't know if it's going to be a
five percent take-up rate then maybe
there should be a cap because right now
this if this bill passes as it is the
state will be liable all the way up to
that hundred million dollars
if there's 100 million dollars available
to help kids in K-12 education a more
efficient way to address the issues that
brought efas to the table in the first
place the fact that some children in
some Public Schools were not getting
their needs met the better way would be
to give more money to the public schools
um after all giving an EFA to a child
whose needs aren't met in a public
school does nothing for the children who
remain in that public school thank you
thank you very much are there questions
from the committee yes representative
luno so thank you very much Mr chair
thank you very much Ms Wilke so is there
a policy distinction then for a policy
committee when considering lifting a cap
that um that could um
open an opportunity for uh for a student
who's currently in a public school to uh
to seek other options versus uh uh
lifting the cap and providing
a tuition rebate taxpayer-funded tuition
rebate for uh families with kids that
were already in private and homeschool
environments are there is there a policy
distinction there I think there is and I
think all hearings and testimony I
listened to study in 2017 the focus was
always on kids in public schools who for
one reason or another were not getting
their needs met and um you know I think
that's that was the policy I was led to
believe was motivating people who were
sponsoring these bills and supporting
them
further questions not see any thank you
very much thank you Mary uh last card we
good morning my name is Jane Bergeron
I'm the executive director of the New
Hampshire Association of special ed
administrators and I hadn't uh intended
to testify today
um but I'm representing special ed
administrators from across the state we
have over 280 members who are leaders in
the field of special education I just
thought it would be important for the
committee to get some clarification on a
question that was brought forward
earlier in the discussion this morning
around
students who have efas who are going
from one public school to another as
recent as last Friday the Bureau of
special education the administrator of
the bureau did inform us that if a child
has an EFA and they go to a public
school outside of their residence it is
the resident School District who is
programmatically and financially
responsible for all aspects of the
child's IEP including Transportation so
I just wanted to put that out to you
according to the bureau administrator
this guidance came from the office of
special education services in Washington
and so we've asked for written
documentation on that but I thought it
would be important for you to have that
question answered
thank you very much are there questions
representative woodcock
thank you chairman thank you for
clarifying that you're welcome because I
know representative Mila has started
with it and I I got confused hearing the
answer and I thought well if you just
said was accurate uh in my mind before
he said that so thank you so much so
just so does in my brain if I'm in
school a it's a public school I'm
getting significant special education
services from the staff and in that
public school district and I go to
public school district B in another town
I still live in a
Public School A is responsibly
extraordinary Capital Transportation yes
very similar to a charter school model
thank you so much I appreciate it thank
you chairman representative luno thank
you very much uh Mr chair and thank you
very much Ms Bergeron for um for that
clarification
um is that response where is that
responsibility spelled out and does it
have a Nexus to either state or federal
law we've asked for that documentation
we've been told it comes from the office
of special ed programs out of Washington
um it was further noted we're going to
have to do the research to get that
because it was further noted that the
department couldn't provide it because
of quick follow-up so we're we're we're
sure though that there's no Nexus to
state law in in are we sure that there's
no Nexus to state law either the 194 F
uh that established the efas or in any
other
to our knowledge like I said we just
learned of this Friday
um and so we're still doing our research
okay thanks very much
representative Cornell Thank you thank
you for taking my question I just want
to be clear about the financial part of
it if you can answer so a student who
lives in Manchester and goes to
Londonderry who receives extensive
special ed but uses your EFA to pay for
Londonderry the special ed services
don't come out of their EFA they get
charged to Manchester and the
transportation that's what it was
explained to us okay thank you very much
representative pattern
so back to representative woodcock's
explanation because A and B is easier
than naming districts could School B
refuse the student
or do they have to receive the student
you know I I think that that's a
question for the school boards and
superintendents in terms of policy and
what is their policy on accepting
students I know they can't discriminate
against the child with an IEP
um certainly I would imagine they could
have a policy saying that they're not
taking any EFA
enrollments I don't know
we we've had that uh statutory issue
come up years ago if they're a open
enrollment school that's a different
deal however the working superintendent
superintendent the superintendent in the
receiving District can say no we're not
accepting any students from school
district a that came down years ago and
I believe it's still in statute I
haven't been here to see it changed so
represent cordelli uh thank you I think
that that also applies to the Manifest
education hardship best answer to the
child where we did have example
um a child was denied admittance to a
neighboring school district and had an
IEP
representative
um thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for taking my question my name is
similar but mine is more refers to a
private out of District placements
because I'm not really sure how this
works if you had a child who labeled
special needs in your district and that
child chose to take an EFA and attend a
private school
that may or may not provide special
services does the home District still
have to provide special education
services for that child once they leave
the school I would have to get
clarification on that when we were just
talking public school to public school
thank you
thank you represent Damon
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question it's helpful to have your
input
so you indicated that what you just
explained was detailed to you on Friday
is it different than what you understood
prior to that is this something new we
hadn't really even had conversations
about efas going public school to public
school
um this is a new situation it's come up
a couple times it's presented conflict
um it's yeah been cause for legal action
and so we reached out and said we need
some guidance
um and that's how the conversation
started thank you you're welcome further
questions from the committee thank you
very much thank you
and with that I'm going to close this
hearing
and we're going to take a five minute
break for those that need to get up in
and the next bill we will be going into
and we'll get right back
foreign
could go that easily so uh and people
across the state for sure so um so
thanks very much members of the
committee this um the bill before you
right now Hospital 432 addresses the uh
the same section of law uh in the
education Freedom accounts as the uh the
prior bill that we just um uh just
discussed uh it doesn't do anything
thing with respect to the um the the
income
eligibility percentage it leaves that
part uh the same and I know there's
there's other bills including the uh
well there's other bills that we've seen
that that do increase the uh the income
eligibility this is this doesn't touch
that
um but um but it what it what it does do
with respect to um uh a student's
eligibility for the program is uh is put
in place an annual uh income uh
recertification process so that a
student's family would every year be uh
be re-certified uh that there or have
their income recertified to be within
the the limits uh required of the
program whether that's 300 percent as in
current law uh which is about ninety
thousand dollars or 350 percent as I
think an amended bill
has some or an amendment to a bill has
suggested be about 105
000 or 500 percent which would be a
hundred and fifty thousand so um so like
I said 432 doesn't make any change to
that number just uh puts in place the
the annual uh income recertification and
um and it also so just sort of looking
at um at at the bill that's what it's
doing in um in the first section and in
the second section it uh it simply talks
about uh what happens to an EFA account
um uh in the event
um the student becomes ineligible so
their family no longer qualifies due to
uh their annual uh income and um and in
that case unused funds revert back to
the education trust fund so um so that's
really that's really the bill in the
nutshell uh I believe what we heard last
week from the governor signaled support
for reusable guard rails on education
Freedom accounts and annual income
recertification is certainly one of
those reasonable guard rails we do it
the um the the state and federal
programs do it in a number of different
areas whether that's housing whether
that's SNAP benefits whether that's
Medicaid
and on and on as far as annual
recertification of income they don't
just test once and then let it go open
loop forever
you test every year and make sure that
the family still qualifies and that's
all we're we're talking about here
reasonable guard rails for um for efas
and um and with that I'll take uh you
know I'll take a couple of quick
questions but hopefully we can get back
on track too thanks represent dry thank
you Mr chairman thank you for taking a
question
um when our family sponsored Cambodian
Refugee uh she and her family were on
Medicaid for a while the problem we
found was that every time that her
income went up a little bit her benefits
declined and she really never gained any
traction at that point I'm wondering if
if someone goes out of the 300 percent
over property level by a little bit and
is not eligible for the program they
really haven't gained enough to make up
the Lost ground that they would lose
from losing an EFA so so I think and
thank thanks for the for the I there's a
question packed in there and and yeah
so but I I I I I do know I do understand
though that um that the federal
guidelines do get updated every year so
that as as people's income you know
Grows by by one or two percent a year
you know whether they're uh you know
government employee or they're on
um you know they're they're they're in a
private company and they're getting a
one two or three percent uh on income
adjustment the the guidelines keep Pace
with that what the guidelines don't do
is is keep Pace with significant changes
in income so so should a family's income
go up by 50 or 100 percent do it due to
a change in job or due to some other
circumstance uh the family is is is
clearly beyond what the what the income
um uh threshold was uh was designed to
be for the for the EFA program and uh
and again I'm I'm not I'm I'm not the
the bill doesn't touch the 300 and and
it would also presume and I think we've
we've talked about this before that you
know with a thousand bills going through
the um uh the House and Senate you know
some of them passed
um you know it's very it's possible that
a bill like this could pass and a bill
raising the income threshold to 350
percent would pass and legislative
Services would put those two bills
together and say okay annual income
certification to 350 percent so this
bill isn't touching the the percentage
part but uh but you know but obviously
legislative services and and Drafting
and putting the other final statutory
changes would uh would have to consider
all the bills that passed follow-up
question
um now I want to just just take a moment
to explain to the committee here
we're going to have to get through all
these bills today if we do not get
through these bills today we will be
meeting next week
representative
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question I was just thinking
about what you were saying as far as
um uh income going up by 200 50 it seems
like more often
people get raises that are you know
keeping up with inflation two percent
five percent so do you have any
understanding of data or statistics as
to what percentage of students would no
longer qualify under efas that are
being
um taken out by only a few percent
versus how many are being taken out by
large income gaps like 50 or 100 yeah so
so you know at the at 300 percent that
takes it right about to um uh actually
just a little bit over median household
income in New Statewide obviously you
know that that uh changes significantly
in from town to town and and north to
south in the state but but Statewide
it's about the median household uh
median household income as that um as
that as that increases you know I think
you're you're you're there would
certainly be a um you know
students that uh that may be in families
that uh from families that I mean if
you're at 301 percent then uh then
you're not you're obviously not going to
be be income eligible but um but again
the these um these these income
guidelines uh do uh do I get adjusted
every year I believe every year
um to uh and and and that would that
would increase that would increase it
for FY 23 and I I think the year starts
in February or something like that so
it's right around now that the new
levels come in and uh and I think for
the first time in this program we're
finally seeing levels that uh don't have
to have lots of commas and and numbers
after that so 300 percent you're talking
90 350 105
000 and 500 is 150 000. so uh so every
um every uh a hundred percent of um of
the poverty level is uh for FY 23s is
thirty thousand dollars so that so
obviously the the EFA program is three
times that at ninety thousand what are
thank you very much terrific thank you
very much Mr chair
I don't have any other pink cards for
this particular bill
so I'm going to close this hearing
and we'll get ready to go
now close we're we're getting there
you got us within 10 minutes that's good
HP 446 I'm going to hand the gavel over
to
um Professor Cordelia I have to be down
in Finance on four bills down there now
so representative cordelli would you
thank you Mr chairman
um this is uh House Bill 446 relative to
the participation in the education
Freedom accounts program by students
with disabilities and uh the prime
Spencer uh representative Cornell is
ready to go thank you good morning for
the record my name is representative
Patty Cornell I represent District 22
Ward 11 I'm Manchester's west side west
side I am introducing House Bill 446 an
act relative to the participation in the
education Freedom accounts program by
students with disabilities and I have an
amendment that I'd also like to
introduce that replaces a bill which
2023-0216h the intent of this bill is to
be a safeguard for parents and children
and to ensure that parents who
parentally place their children with a
disability in a for-profit private
school are not included in the
definition of parentally placed private
school children with with disabilities
parents should be adequately informed
and revised receive advanced notice of a
potential consequence and I'm not saying
that they aren't and that somebody
during the application process might say
something to them I just think it would
be better for parents and their students
that it'd be something in writing that
they are handed and are aware of
according to the education Freedom
account vendor spending report dated
June 30th 2022 there are at least seven
for-profit schools where the accounts
are used and where 75 students attend
some of those schools are actin Academy
Lupine Montessori median house
Montessori Bedford Academy and a few
more I do not know of students with
disabilities attend those schools but
they could and if they are they're not
entitled to the special education
so in summary this bill is just intended
to make parents informed before making a
that's all thank you questions from the
committee
I have one
um
in terms of
the parentally placed student
in a private school
um
they do have
uh certain rights under idea I think as
you defined in the um in the USC code
here is it am I correct I I may I maybe
maybe misunderstood what you were saying
earlier
this isn't all private schools this is
for-profit private schools
which I believe are not covered under
this
and I think there are speakers that are
signed up to speak after me that could
explain to those rules better than I do
than I can
so I might defer to them okay thank you
for the questions
yes representative luno thank you very
much Mr chair thank you very much
representative Cornell bringing this in
so um your your would it would it be
clear that your intent here isn't to
deprive students rights that they're
entitled to but clarify what what um
what they're what their rights are uh in
the situations they may PR that may
present through in the EFA program thank
thank you representative luno that is
correct and as we heard the governor and
his um budget address to the education
finance committee last week he's not
opposed to safeguards for the efas and I
think this is a safeguard for parents
and children with disabilities if they
attend these schools
thank you see no further questions thank
you very much thank you
next we have Vanessa Blaise
from New Hampshire Council on
developmental disabilities
thank you members of the committee I'll
be very brief my name is Vanessa Blaise
I serve as the Director of policy and
planning for the New Hampshire Council
on developmental disabilities
um and I'm here um because the council
supports uh HB 446
we feel that this bill merely requires
informing parents of students acts who
access Support Services in school what
their rights are
um we're not asking anyone to change
those rights or to make determinations
about what kinds of services private
for-profit schools are providing but
making it so that parents understand
what they are um they have the rights to
um
if the purpose of the EFA is for parents
to have more control over their students
education then we think that it is very
important that they understand what
their students rights are under the
federal guidelines there's a lot of
confusion as to what is a public school
a non-public school a charter school a
private for-profit school and we think
that for parents to be able to make the
best decision about their children's
education that we should be providing
them all of the information that they
need in the letter that I had handed out
is attached a very simple table
that briefly it is not in depth but
briefly explains what students rights
are under idea
um when it comes to a for-profit versus
non-profit schools
um so again we are in support of the
spell we feel that it's merely a
housekeeping bill
um to be sure that parents are able to
make the best decisions that they can
when they're using the EFA program thank
you
questions
uh I have one
um the distinction you're making for uh
for-profit versus non-profit private
schools that is covered in section 1412
as specified in the bill
I'm sorry I have to take a look at the
belt sure
I'm not quite sure if I understand what
your what your question is I
was uh actually I'll have an amendment
coming also
um so I have looked at section 1412 and
I don't remember seeing the distinction
between for-profit and non-profit in
there and I'm just wondering where that
distinction is in law well in in the
distinction in law would be that a
for-profit school is a for-profit
business
and it is not a um some some
non-profit schools are associated with
public education through the public
education system some are not
but a private for-profit school is
thank you any further questions
see none thank you very much for being
here thank you
thank you my name is Bonnie Dunham and
I'm here as a private citizen as a
parent
um and regardless of how I might feel
about education Freedom accounts I think
it's very important that parents
receive all of the information they need
to make an informed decision about
whether they choose to participate in
that program which is the intent of this
bill so thank you for that I have two
concerns though both of which I believe
are addressed in the amendment the first
is on the statement that participation
in the EFA program is the parental
placement under 20 USC 1412 a10a doesn't
specify that it only applies to a
parental placement in a school or
facility that meets the definition of an
elementary or secondary school it does
not include children who are
homeschooled or who are placed in a
for-profit private school using an EFA
and the reason for that is while 1412
doesn't specify that exactly it says
children with disabilities in the state
who are enrolled by their parents in
private elementary schools and secondary
schools and the definition of an
elementary and secondary school in the
IDS statute regulations and in the
elementary and secondary Education Act
specify that those are non-profit
institutional day or residential schools
and so that's where that comes from and
that's further emphasized in a letter
from the office of special education
programs to Chapman who asked that
question way back in 2007 although not
specifically about education Freedom
accounts and then the U.S the New
Hampshire Department of Education issued
a memo in 2010 memo number 38 to address
that same question and that also says
only non-profit public schools that are
approved by the New Hampshire Department
of Education fall into the private
school requirement for idea
so if a parent enrolls their child with
a disability in an EFA using an EFA in a
public or private non-profit Elementary
or secondary school then that means that
the child is considered to be apparently
placed child with a disability under
idea
while the child no longer has an
individual right to Summer all of the
special education and related services
that child would receive if enrolled in
a public school they may receive some
Services through the Equitable Services
provision of idea
if on the other hand the child is
enrolled by their parent in a for-profit
private school or homeschooled neither
which meet the definition of an
elementary or secondary school the child
would not be considered to be a
parentally placed child with a
disability and would have no right to
any special education or related
Services Under the idea the Equitable
Services requirement provides that the
Lea School District must spend an amount
proportionate to the amount of idea
funds they receive for the group of
parentally placed private school
children with disabilities attending
private elementary or secondary schools
in the school district served by the Lea
children who are not enrolled in in
those schools children who are enrolled
in for-profit private schools or who are
homeschooled do not receive any idea
funds Ida does not provide school
districts any funds for children in
for-profit private schools or who are
homeschooled so the Equitable
education or the pro-rada share doesn't
apply it's just not not equivalent
um
School District though how Woods
continue to be responsible justice for
all children for child find activities
meaning evaluating a child who they
suspect to have a disability
and reevaluating at least once every
three years to determine if the child
continues to that again allows the
parent to make an informed decision
and that's not paid forth through idea
funds that's generally paid for through
local tax dollars my second concern is
that the language in in the um
in the current bill does not
specify that what it says in 34 CFR
300.137 and the idea regulations no
parentally placed private school child
with a disability has an individual
right to receive some or all of the
special education services that the
child would receive if enrolled in a
public school and then they go into the
whole formula and process for
determining how to provide Equitable
Services
and while that's not in the statute the
comments in the Ida regulation state
that it reflects the Department's
long-standing policy consistent with the
act and explicitly provides that
children with disabilities enrolled in
private schools by their parents have no
individual entitlement
under the Act leas only have an
obligation to provide parentally placed
private school children with
disabilities an opportunity for
Equitable participation in the services
funded with Federal Part B funds that
the lease Lea has determined after
meaningful And Timely consultation with
private schools to make available to the
population of parentally placed private
school children with disabilities they
are not required to spend more than
their proportionate Federal share on
those services
um
I ask that you please add language to
make clear both of those points and I
believe the amendment does that by
including a reference to 34 CFR Point
137 and stating that the scholarship
organization's explanation that's
provided to parents of children with
disabilities who are considering an EFA
specify that a parental placement under
idea means a parental placement by a
parent in a school or facility that
meets the definition of an elementary or
secondary school there's a typo there
Elementary or secondary school under 20
USC
1401 and then I've included copies of
all of the referenced materials excerpts
from the idea statute regulations the
letter to Chapman and the New Hampshire
Department of education's memo number
38.
thank you thank you uh questions
representative miler uh thank you Mr
chair and thank you uh Miss Dunham for
being here
uh for the uh information of the new
members of this committee
Miss Dunham has been
a huge parental advocate for special
education
in my 10 years here in this uh body and
she has been with the parent parental
information service for special ed
parents and has been a huge reference
for this committee and I appreciate you
being here even with your disabled hip
that you are managing I'm glad I'm glad
you're here I just wanted to make sure
that the committee understood the
reference of what she's coming and she's
just been terrific with this committee
thank you for being my hips are fine I
just have to I fractured my pelvis in
two places which is both better and
worse and so
uh thank you any further questions
I've seen none thank you very much uh oh
I'm sorry representative Cornell Thank
you for coming here today and explaining
this better than I did so thank you very
much oh thank you it's very confusing
see no further questions thank you very
much for being here
um and I do not believe we have any
no one else to testify
we can close the hearing on House Bill
446 and we have a few minutes until 11
and time to get back in action with
House Bill 603
relative to Education Service Providers
under the education Freedom accounts
program and it looks like the bill will
be introduced by uh representative
Woodcock thank you thank you chairman
cordelli representative Woodcock from uh
Conway New Hampshire pleasure to be here
uh representing uh representative Tana
who is away uh in lieu of the time in in
the Chairman's uh Lads briefing I will
keep this brief and limit my responses
um that that being said this is a bill
that tries to once again put a few God
rails into the EFA pieces and I'm sure
that you're following on along with me
uh specifically uh under a couple of uh
Clarity pieces for the education and
service provider uh the first one under
a is the idea that the provider needs
his business or their business or their
school or whatever whatever program
they're using the needs to be in
operation for a year and representative
is concerned about the financial
stability of a program site and then
falling off the second one and and I
would make note that this talks about
providing instruction to students in a
public non-public school uh the chorus
lawn and align with Ed 400 there was
some question about that it
representative Lucas may have a question
and and has some valid points on that uh
moving forward the other couple pieces
is a concern when students go to some of
these providers that perhaps the
location may not be as safe and not any
safety standards that they typically
would uh for students particularly in
the uh mechanical areas and then finally
the last one is is critically important
and that is the continued request for a
criminal background check for uh
providers that are working with students
uh as it would be in public school
anyone that's dealing with direct
instruction so that's the Four Points of
Representative Tana's bill I appreciate
the fact that I'm a co-sponsor but I
will tell you candidly she knows a lot
more about this than I do and I'll be
happy to take any questions I can answer
which would be a very brief number
thank you
um
so I'm just wondering
as you know how
this would apply this section B if
providing instruction to students
it needs to be an approved non-public
school education program pursuant to
Department of Education blah blah blah
so the question is what about Stu tutors
what about
um music instruct you know
music instruction that type of thing
they are not schools they are
individuals right and and uh I
appreciate that question the Robinson
lake is particularly uh to the knowledge
you made that prior uh concern uh last
year when a civil bill came forward and
I think you're right I think there this
I don't know
um and perhaps represent cordelli does I
don't know if rule had 40 had a further
definition of whether it is but I would
be uh happy to uh talk with
representative which comes back and and
amend that to take your concern into the
question I think you have a valid point
I don't know Canley is the new e400 uh
rules have that enough but but you make
a valid point thank you very much
further questions representative Belcher
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
um as you know efas have been
um quite popular perhaps more popular
than was originally expected a large
number of students have registered for
them so I'm looking at item uh 2A if new
providers wanted to enter the
marketplace to meet this increased
Demand with item a prohibit them from
being able to do so because they're not
in operation for your
thank you for the question Reverend
velker uh my thinking is your answer
would be yes it would preclude them from
being participatory uh for the first
year this the intent of the a is to make
sure that the organization that's
working with the students has Financial
capabilities to last for the year so the
youngster to start a program that it
goes belly up I mean most most of the
providers that you'll see I'm sure that
others here who are into the EFA program
when they when you look at a list of
providers have been around a while
any further questions see none thank you
very much thank you Mr appreciate it
and we have uh
uh thank you Mr chair members of the
committee for the opportunity to provide
testimony today uh my name is Sarah
Scott and I'm the director of Grassroots
operations with Americans for Prosperity
in New Hampshire and on behalf of
Americans for Prosperity New Hampshire
and our activists across the state we'd
ask that you oppose this bill I'll keep
this pretty brief I just wanted to go
over a couple of the highlights here so
primarily the requirement that these
service providers be in operation for a
minimum of one year I think this really
restricts Us in terms of innovation as
well as opportunity for new service
providers to enter the market we're
seeing education changing at such a
rapid rate that we could be missing out
on lots of innovative programs by
requiring them to be in operation for a
year we're also restricting teachers
abilities to become tutors for this
program so if the teacher decided that
they wanted to do this on the side or
they wanted to exit the traditional
public school system and become a tutor
uh this bill would say that they can't
become a tutor for the EFA program
unless they've been in operation for a
year so I think placing an arbitrary
limit by saying that even if you've been
teaching in the school system for 25
years you have to be in operation as an
EFA provider for a year before you can
get that funds
um is really limiting who we can take
advantage of in terms of Education
providers
um
also that it seems like the points have
already been addressed about uh the
approved Public School A lot of these
organizations are not schools they are
organizations or they're sports teams or
they are otherwise outside of the
non-public school system but sounds like
those issues have already been addressed
so primarily my opposition is about that
minimum of one year
um so uh with that I'll just conclude
and happy to take any questions
thank you very much
any questions for Miss Scott
see none get off very easy today thank
you
I do not believe we have any further
cards if there's no one else interested
in testifying
I'll close the hearing on House Bill 603
and
um maybe a little extra lunch time for
uh committee members as we will
reconvene at one o'clock for house bill
573.
foreign
I just want to apologize I completely
forgot after I introduced my bill that I
wasn't supposed to come back to my seat
and sit down and and then I asked a
question of Miss Dunham and I'm not
supposed to do that so I completely
forgot and I'm sorry for not following
the rules
thanks
okay good okay we're ready to go ahead
with the hearings for this afternoon the
first bill is 573. this bill limiting
education Freedom account funding to
budgeted amounts representative lunal
Prime responsibilities here thank you
very much Mr chair members of the
committee for the record Dave luno
representing people of Miramar County
District 9 living in the towns of uh
Beau and Hopkinton and and um I'm here
to offer the committee House Bill 573
which which continues our you know
efforts to uh to to put some guard rails
and um
and transparency and accountability and
oversight on the uh the state's um
education Freedom account program so
um so HP 573 actually uh came
uh came out of drafting
um
um and and with no and I don't mean
anything negative against our very very
hard working and uh and skilled
legislative service drafting uh
attorneys but um it was signed off I
signed off on it pending um pending
final
um uh final Drafting and so it did it
did come at us with uh with an error
that'll that'll get um I'll get to in a
moment but excuse me the uh the emphasis
on um on 573 is uh is basically to
provide some uh some accountability uh
and uh and transparency when the state
budgets for um
for Education Freedom accounts and two
years ago at this time the Department of
Education Department of Education had
had indicated during the I think it was
during the Senate uh process of of
budget development that education
Freedom accounts were going to cost
somewhere on the neighborhood of a
hundred and thirty thousand dollars in
the first year and three million dollars
in the second year and I think as we all
know uh uh over that period of time it's
uh come in uh closer to 25 million
dollars and uh we were we were warned
the legislature was warned during the
budget process last year by um by the uh
office of legislative budget assistant
that that it could
uh that the state could face obligations
uh under the program closing in on 70
million dollars so uh uh so while it uh
while it wasn't 70 million well it
didn't turn out to be a 70 million
dollar exposure it did come out to be
close to a 25 million dollar exposure
which is a lot more than what the
Department of Education had uh um had
had let on and um and so this um this is
pretty simple it um
it just holds the uh the program
um to the to the bud to not to exceed
the budgeted months and uh and you know
we do that and every um every aspect of
our um of our budgeting process we know
how many kids go to uh go to public
schools in the year before that gets
budgeted in the in the first year of the
budget and carried through into the
second year of the budget the um uh
in other departments outside of
Education Commissioners and department
heads and program heads have to talk
about what their department needs are
and and those numbers get get put into
the budget the um the budget assistant
said hey you know the education Freedom
account is really a blank check and
that's not something that we've done in
any other program in the state so I'm
I'm not doing it because I'm saying that
we shouldn't be spending um State
dollars or taxpayer dollars on education
Freedom accounts I'm not doing it
because
um because I don't think the state
should pay for private school or home
school tuition bills I'm doing it
because taxpayer money is being used and
it should be budgeted uh appropriately
and and uh State officials need to be
held accountable if their budgets are
not even close as they haven't been in
the first two years of this program to
what was uh what was presented so
so there's a couple other areas where
where um where I think we've we've seen
uh this type of um
type of language or this type of
budgeting process used when it comes to
uh to education we do it in special
education Aid
the finance committee budgets during the
budget process somewhere somewhere it's
usually around 30 or 32 or 33 million
dollars for special education aid and
there's a provision in that statute that
if those numbers are not satisfactory
then every school district will get a
prorated share of that so uh so if if 32
million dollars if that was budgeted and
that only paid for 75 percent of the
True Value then then every every
District would receive 75 percent of
that budgeted amount I don't think it's
ever been that drastically off budget
but I think sometime in recent memory it
has been 90 or 95 percent
um uh prorated another example to use
would be the education tax credit uh
program which by Statute
God which same as a budget
um is is budgeted in this case at 5.1
million dollars and um and uh I don't
believe in the education tax uh credit
program that that um that the
participant that the number of
participating students in the grants
they received have um have have have
come up against that um that cap and um
uh honestly I'm not quite sure what
would happen if they do come up to the
cap but uh but we've certainly got got
examples like in special education Aid
where it was prorated and um and uh uh
and I think another way to do it is you
don't prorate it and you um you know you
issue um uh the um the scholarships
until the money runs out and uh and then
you may be able to provide some sort of
priority or or maybe more accurate
budgeting in um in in future years but
uh but it certainly puts some
accountability on um on you know what uh
what's being told during the during the
budget process and some accountability
on the department for that so um so just
going going quickly
um uh down the bill
uh on page um on just the inside first
page of the bill uh the amounts uh to
fund the grants of transfers are hereby
appropriated from the Department uh from
from the from the education trust fund
but then it um it it
strikes a lot of the the language in
there right now that doesn't have any
accountability to budgeted amounts and
um and and basically picks up
um
with I want to make sure such warrant
for payment shall
and and this is where the error is on
line 12.
um that first part on line 12 should not
be in there that was left over from FY
23 and it's not even not even meaningful
for this but but it should pick up at
the end of line 12 so such weren't for
payment shall not exceed the amounts
appropriated for such purpose in the
biennial State operating budget and
that's it it's just truth and budgeting
and and hopefully this is something that
that can be bipartisan that people
understand because we do it all over
state government your cities and towns
uh do it that's what uh you know we're
coming up in March for for many of our
towns will hold School District meeting
and their annual Town meetings and
that's exactly what we do uh uh during
these meetings and if school boards
present their budget select boards
present their budget and they're held
accountable to those uh to stay within
those those budget it's during the
ensuing year so
so I'm not asking any more from from the
state to be responsible with taxpayer
dollars when uh when budgeting for
Education Freedom accounts so that's uh
what I've got here I'm happy to take a
couple questions thank you very much are
there questions from the committee yes
representative
I'm curious how you came up with 25
million dollars for this year
so I just did a quick calculation and
it's nowhere near that no I didn't say
for the for this year for the first two
years of the program I think it was
something like training them yeah yeah I
and that's what I said was for the first
represent Belcher
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking the question
um you compared the possibility of
prorating this program with the way that
we do special education funding when the
amount runs out it's prorated
um
but when the amount Runs Out in special
education versus this program
um would parents have to pick up the
cost in special education when it runs
out because it seems like they would in
this program
no in in special education funding these
are grants that go to school districts
so parents do pick up the uh the tab
through their their local education
property tax absolutely do if I I think
I misspelled a little bit uh I'm
suggesting that when when the amount is
run out and they have to prorate
um
the amount that is received for special
education
anything over that amount that is not
paid for by the state Grant is that
amount coming directly out of the
parents pockets of the special education
child oh no no because that special
education is absolutely something that
that is is um uh you know directed to to
the state by federal law and I'm really
at the boundary of my my um you know uh
conversion
um you know understanding of this but uh
but not a dime of that comes out of um
out of out of a parent's personal
thank you wallet further questions from
the committee represent cordelli
thank you
when the budget cap or the budgeted
amount is reached what happens to other
students who are in line to apply yeah I
think that's a really good question and
I was I was hoping to find that answer
in the tax credits in the education tax
credit program and I did it it did not
um it wasn't clear to me in that program
that that that it had been defined there
either
um uh uh but I think I think it
certainly would be would be you know
responsible on part of the the
commissioner to uh to put in a budget
that that that that that the
commissioner feels will satisfy the
needs of that program at least we all go
into the budget process Eyes Wide Open
knowing exactly what this program might
uh might be costing based on all the
best information that the commissioner
of education has as opposed to I I don't
know how frankly in in business you
would you would be you would be out of a
job in a heartbeat if you um you you
propose you said something was going to
cost three million dollars and ended up
costing closer to 25 million dollars
that is just laughable so so
um it was pretty obvious during the
creation of that program that uh that a
number of students a number of families
of students who were in
um private schools and homeschooled uh
had already were already being in those
um in those education environments would
uh would qualify for vouchers uh we've
got over 20 000 students that would that
would that are in those programs and um
for some reason the Department of
Education said we think maybe four of
them will Avail themselves of a of a
five six seven thousand dollar check I
mean that's just phony budgeting that's
just irresponsible budgeting and and all
we're trying to do is uh is put some
guard rails on a program that the that
the governor has suggested could
probably use some
further questions from the committee
not seeing thank you very much great
thanks very much Mr chairman
are there any other pink cards for this
bill
Bonnie
we're on um 573
okay yeah
I know we had what maybe some pile of
one of those
yeah
look at the last several bills and see
that we're looking for and it says 573.
um
okay
well that's going back pretty early in
the morning there okay thank you
um my name is Bonnie Dunham and I'm from
Merrimack New Hampshire and when I read
this bill I looked at it from the
perspective of a parent of a child with
a disability my son Sean is a young
adult with intellectual and
developmental disabilities and other
complex disabilities he's funny Charming
hard-working handsome and a good citizen
he's proud that he's worked at Wendy's
for more than 20 years and is a fully
participating and contributing member of
his community
but he relies on Services through the
developmental Services System area
agencies in order to continue living a
life of value and dignity this is the
budget year so soon I and many other
families will be spending our afternoons
and evenings at budget hearings to
advocate for adequate funding for the
services that our loved ones need not
that they want that they need often just
to survive I resent that while I will be
testifying at what one parent calls the
biennial begathon
and then having to work with the amount
budgeted the EFA program has no such
constraints it's like a program with a
platinum card with no credit limit
that's not fair and it's not right and I
hope you support this Bill thank you
thank you are there any questions on
oh I'll fill this out thank you back in
are we supposed to wipe the microphone
thank you
anymore
okay are there any other pink cards we
have for this bill
not see any we will close to hearing for
okay
okay the 20
and start the hearing on
HBA 621
this is relative to funds of the
education Freedom accounts program after
termination of a student's participation
and responsibilities of the scholarship
organization
Prime sponsor is representative little
welcome representative Luna thank you
very much Mr chair members of the
committee for the record David luno
representing the people of Merrimack
County District 9 the towns of Beau and
Hopkinton and I'd like to include
Concord in that too
so I'm I'm honored to bring forward
House Bill 621 it's the uh the the final
one in um and I think our our basket of
of accountability transparency and
oversight bills with respect to the
education Freedom account uh program and
uh if
if 621 looks familiar to uh to some of
the members on this committee it's
because it is and
um and it was uh brought forward
um by its prime sponsor last year uh
former member representative Bonnie Hamm
and um and uh as as she did last year uh
this bill also has bipartisan
sponsorship uh on it and uh and is a
relatively light touch on the the EFA
program and I hope tightening up some
Provisions that that we all
um agree make sense and so so without
um a whole lot of delay and taking up
the committee's time I'll sort of turn
to um turn to the first section of the
of the bill
and it's directed to to changes when a
uh when an EFA student enrolls as a
full-time student in their resident
Public School District and um and
basically it uh it it
makes it simple
um the if an EFA student enrolls
full-time in their
Public School District where they live
in in of their residence then um then
number one
immediate suspension of payments of
additional funds into the student's EFA
so these are funds that are directed
from the Department of Education they
come out of the trust fund and they get
deposited into the the EFA number two it
terminates the EFA and number three any
remaining funds being transferred back
uh I mean sorry in the EFA in that
student CFA get transferred back to the
education trust fund the um the rest of
the
um the bill
tightens up
Provisions in the in 194 f with respect
to suspected cases of Fraud and um and
it basically considers
the
uh what the scholarship organization's
responsibility uh uh is when uh when
there's a suspected cases of fraud it
talks about what the student's
eligibility uh will be in in terms of
continuing in the uh the EFA program
when they're suspect suspected cases of
Fraud and um and then I think most
importantly on lines 28 through 30
it changes the word may to shall when uh
when the scholarship organization
uh
identifies a suspected case of fraud
that it shall
refer those uh cases to the attorney
general for investigation and um and
that's that's basically it
um
what happens to uh to the efas when a
full-time when a EFA student enrolls
full-time in their public school
district of residence it's where they
live and what happens when there's
that's really it I mean I hope
that uh that you know the the the light
touch that uh that house bill 621 makes
on the uh the the existing EFA statute
is something that's uh certainly
reasonable and acceptable by all the
members of this committee uh I don't
have any reason to think that the uh
that the governor would would find these
changes to be anything less than some of
the most reasonable changes that that
you would put in place to number one
protect uh local taxpayers uh interests
and um and number and also right there
with it protect the interest of of
taxpayers um all across the state uh in
the case that um or in cases where where
there might be a suspected case of of
fraud which uh which um does happen we
heard the commissioner say it uh it
happens in other states and um and uh so
I think having the uh having those guard
rails here in New Hampshire would would
make a lot of
uh with that I'll conclude remarks and
take a few questions thank you very much
uh represent McDonald
thank you Mr chair thank you again
I'm looking specifically at page one the
last paragraph lines 28 for 30. it says
a scholarship organization shall refer
suspected cases of substantial misuse of
EFA funds to the attorney general for
investigation and then the bill strikes
out if evidence of fraudulent use of EFA
funds is obtained
so would this bill or is the intent of
this bill to increase the number of
trials that proceed without evidence and
do not have an evidential basis and
wouldn't that increase
the amount of money going forward in
trials and that's an added expense no no
thank you thank you very very much for
the question no it simply refers it to
the Eternal attorney general for
investigation and um and you know it it
um
you know the Attorney General is in a
very unique um has a very unique role in
New Hampshire because they've got
trained law enforcement
officials on their staff that are that
know how to professionally handle
investigations draw out ever evidence
and and determine whether or not
something is fit to to go to a trial
because I agree in some cases you may
want to take this to trial if if the
fraud if the amount of fraud represents
you know was was beyond a certain number
I think it may qualify for one level of
um of um of misdemeanor if it's above
another number it's it qualifies for a
different level of of misdemeanor and um
and the Attorney General I think is is
in a position to investigate it collect
that evidence and um and I you know I
I'm I'm not going to speak for what the
um children's scholarships has in terms
terms of
investigatory
capacity but but I think should the
should the children's scholarship fund
have a reason to suspect fraud
and they're the ones that are reviewing
all of the requests that come in then
they can get it off their lap and get it
over the Attorney General's office
Attorney General's office investigates
and then I go hey you know what not a
problem here so to summarize what you
said the intent of the bill is not to
increase the number of Trials nor the
expenses relating to trials but that
might be the result it may be the it it
may be the result if um if if New
Hampshire
experiences what has been experienced in
other states uh where uh where where
there have been cases of of substantial
fraud which is a which is a rip-off on
the taxpayers and I certainly think the
taxpayers in New Hampshire would expect
the Attorney General to would expect
that the Attorney General respects their
taxpayer money uh is is going towards um
towards
purposes that were designed as as as as
important by the program and not to take
advantage of um you know of public money
okay thank you represent Belcher
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking the question I'd just like to
follow up just a little bit on the line
of questioning uh Rhett McDonald was on
on page 128 through 30. can you just
speak a little bit to the rationale
behind requiring the scholarship
organization to refer cases to the
attorney general who does Criminal
investigations
when there is no evidence of fraud
because that last line is struck here
yeah so so you know if the scholarship
organization has um has refer suspected
uh cases of substantial misuse so so
obviously you know the the Department of
Education has rule-making Authority
Under 541a where they can Define what
substantial misuses I'm sure in
collaboration with the Department of
Justice they can determine what that
level it is whether that means five
hundred dollars or five thousand dollars
or fifty thousand dollars I I you know
that's beyond I think our pay grade but
um but I think the um the that could be
borne out in rules and uh you know we we
uh we did not we left the word
substantial in there so I mean this
isn't about misappropriating a postage
stamp on uh on something it's got to
obviously be greater than some
reasonable threshold
um to what to to be captured and under
the substantial misuse if I may just
real briefly follow up
um can you speak at all to the
difference in New Hampshire criminal
code between substantial misuse and
fraud
I I can't no thank you but if there's an
attorney from the um from the Department
of Education perhaps they would be able
to
further questions from the committee
going to representative Damon
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question
um so would it be correct to conclude
given lines 19 20 through
sorry uh 24.
that
if this is already those lines well it's
changing made a shout
so if those actions the audit and so
forth are taking place that seems to me
it would lead to either everything is
fine or something is amiss and therefore
the data to refer to the Attorney
General's office would be
rationally obtained yeah I think that's
a reasonable conclusion for me thank you
for the questions representative Ford
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question I'm a bit concerned about
the immediacy excuse me
that's that's a purpose to my question
is how would you provide some protection
for some step that had been taken to
assist the student I think of physical
things like a hearing aid or or
something which might not be completely
paid for or something it might be
contracted for for a period of time and
not be finished and if you immediately
suspend payment then they might not
complete something which is part of the
process of helping them improve and I
that that was my my concern with the
with the immediacy language yeah yeah
and and I think that's uh I think that's
a fair question and and and there's
there's probably enough enough here
where rules could um could could could
tighten up on on that a little bit more
but but I think it also sets a fairly
High bar for the um for for rule making
suspect a substantial uh
misuse of EFA funds uh what what that is
and and you know if it wasn't any
example of of um of a um you know a
hearing device or something like that
maybe that wouldn't qualify but uh you
know in Arizona uh somebody bought I
think a um a um uh you know some sort of
you know you know uh what are they
called The Wave Runners the sea Doos uh
and uh and you know and those usually
cost thousands and thousands of dollars
and and that probably created a red flag
for um for the um the you know the con
the company or or the the department
that oversees the the accounts in
Arizona to say hey you know what maybe
we got something going on here
further questions from the committee
represent cordelli
thank you along those same lines
representative I'm looking more up at
the top five through uh 13.
um and enrolling back in your resident
Public School District there still could
be outstanding
charges
the scholarship fund goes through an
extensive auditing period
when they get
an invoice for a payment for an
educational expense
and if you cut off
the remaining funds in their account and
terminate the account right when they
enroll
um aren't we in danger of
um stopping a parent from being
reimbursed for a computer or something
like that possibly
um uh thanks thanks for the question I
mean this is a student that was uh was
an EFA student and is now going back
into their public school I you know if
if they if the day before they put in
for uh for uh uh I don't know like a
1200 reimbursement for um for a laptop
to be able to take that back into their
Public Schools I I don't know I mean I I
know I I I think many taxpayers would
say that's not what the EFA program was
about
um uh if students are planning on being
in their Public School leave for a day
get a laptop and then go back into their
public school you know I I think that
would would honestly if it didn't if it
didn't get caught in the first section I
think probably should get caught in the
second section
further questions of the committee
I want to just follow up on that but
that wasn't the point of my question but
it says the EFA that has been open for
at least one full school year
and so that's not going to be leave for
a day get a laptop and go back that's
going to be something they were working
on and then whatever happened they
decided maybe their life changed and
they could no longer homeschool them I
mean whatever and now they have to
enroll the kid but they've already
committed contracted to have whatever it
was that was ordered and they're waiting
for reimbursement yeah you know you know
possibly the product could be returned
uh I know uh you know at least the the I
think the number one vendor in the EFA
program has a pretty generous um you
know return uh policy and uh you know if
that covers those the majority of maybe
that specific case you know I I
yeah you know I I I I I I just think
it's it's it's pretty straightforward
that if you're enrolling as a full-time
student in your resident School District
that uh that you know you're you're
you're you're you're terminating the EFA
and uh and funds drop back into the
education trust fund because the
education trust fund uh will have um
you know we'll have you know costs that
it needs to uh you know in terms of
adequacy that it needs to uh send to the
school district too so now the question
that I was going to ask if that's okay
and that is do you see this
sort of I guess use it or lose it kind
of rule that your law that you're
putting in being something that would
encourage student with discourage
parents from saving EFA money because
things with things when you're in later
grades cost more than when you're in
younger grades and so it would make
sense for parents to
save that money so when they get in the
older grades they have it available for
you know the more expensive things and
do you think this would encourage saving
or discourage saving if if they realize
that oh if something happens and my kid
has to go back in the school we've lost
it all even if it's just for a year they
have to go back yeah so if if a student
is is exiting the EFA to go back to
their um their their public school I
think this I stand by the language here
that that you terminate the account and
uh and you just move forward they've
obviously made some decisions if they
want to wait for the laptop to arrive
and get reimbursed and then go back in I
mean families can make make their own
decisions I think if a family did make a
decision based on that wait till the
check comes in to pay for the laptop and
then drop the EFA the next day and ran
to their public school I think taxpayers
might feel that that they got cheated on
that one
brother further questions representative
Cornell
if this is a question for a rep Luna but
um replica just said that they might
save up in the earlier grades for
something bigger in the later grades and
I didn't know there was carryover on is
there you can save it from year to year
represent Balboni again I'm sorry
because I didn't realize that either I
have another question so literally you
can save it all the if you start your
child in kindergarten and you don't use
up the funds every year you're in the
program you can save an undetermined
amount of money if you don't use it
and there's no limit I've never read
anything about that right yeah yeah you
can roll over the funds from year to
we'll have Kate answer that as soon as
um I've got a question for you though um
uh a young man is going to Argyle is
going to a Montessori School in using
EFA money to pay for that
paid all the tuition at the front side
after four weeks decides up I'm going to
come back to the regular Public School
the money's already been sent to the
Montessori what what's the relationship
of the parent now do they have to
obligate to pay that money back or
what's the deal here I I have no idea
how that how that works and uh that may
be a good question for uh for Ms Demers
okay
further questions uh rep San luno not
seeing any uh thank you very much thank
you very much uh okay you know I know
you didn't fill out a pink card or I
don't have one on but are you there for
technical support too
several questions were asked could you
help us out with those
yeah okay
Baker from children's scholarship fund
thanks this is exactly why I hung around
for technical support
it is not use it or lose it the
education Freedom accounts so to
increase the family's way of looking at
it so that they'll be fiscally
responsible so in other states when
people found that they gave money to
families and they said you have a
thousand dollars you have to use it they
didn't use it the way we would want them
to use it in New Hampshire with our kind
of you know fiscal Prudence so making
the amount that they don't use roll
forward into the next year encourages
them to be fiscally responsible because
they don't have that emergency feeling
like oh no I'm going to lose this money
so I better use it there's a small
percentage of families that do like
representative leckis described think
ahead
and they're thinking when I get to
Middle School the tuition is going to be
higher so I'm going to use x amount of
money out of my education Freedom
account to pay for things now and then
when I get there I'm going to make a
bigger payments and so it is you know a
grant given to the family and so the way
to think about it is once you've given
it to the family now it's in their
responsibility where they're saying I'm
going to use x amount of money now and
I'm going to use this money later for
something else so does that help answer
yes representative mailer thank you Mr
chair uh thank you for taking my
question what's the average EFA
48 and some change and um the Department
of Education has a page now on their
website where all of these reports are
and the one at the top is a grid where
you can see all the children that are in
the program on that that's where they're
saying it's 48 for this school year
yeah
so could you please answer that question
about the other question the Montessori
School yeah so we actually would ask the
Montessori School in that case to return
the tuition that was unused for the
child and we have a mechanism where you
know if someone purchases something
because we have the digital wallet
platform they can return the money right
into the child's education Freedom
account and so in that case we would ask
say you were there for six months and
then you withdrew from the Montessori
school but you had prepaid for the other
six months we would ask the Montessori
School to return that money to the
child's education Freedom account how
does that work many colleges you know if
you withdraw in the first few days you
get 80 back and then if you you know do
it after that you don't get anything
back in terms of tuition in my
experience the schools are not looking
at this money like that they're looking
at this like they know it's money coming
from the education Freedom account they
know that the intended purpose is for
that child and so we could make an
argument for example Rick that if they
kept that money it wouldn't fit in a
category right because that money is for
tuition for the child it's not to cover
their operating costs so I could make an
argument that if they kept the money and
didn't return it like we would ask them
to that it's not an eligible expense
then
that raised a lot of questions but I
mean yeah I think it's in good faith
that they would turn their money to the
child's education Freedom account if
they're not educating the child because
in most cases the families are choosing
something else that they would direct
that money too I see and so they're not
retaining money that doesn't directly
relate to the student
and maybe I've made the rules too strict
but you know representative Wright thank
you chairman thank you uh can you help
us out and uh do you know any examples
of reasons someone might want to keep a
an EFA account open for a little while
longer once they've re-enrolled in a
public school so the the reason that
they did wrote this in the law the
legislators if I remember correctly we
might better ask representative cordelli
than me but again was to keep that so
that it's not use it or lose it right so
you're not feeling that emergency to
spend the money on things that you don't
need and then secondarily if you go back
to your public school you might still
have needs for example there's quite a
few families that contact us that might
be enrolled in their public school
full-time who wish they also could use
the education Freedom account for
tutoring and supplies and so because
it's the grant awarded to the child if
it's for the child's expenses then it's
being spent properly
so you might spend it down on tutoring
for example you return to your public
school but you're hopeful that you could
use a tutor still that you were using
for math in the afternoons you might
continue to spend down the money in your
Grant on a tutor
yeah
and then in that case it would just stay
open until it reaches zero there's no
time limit on it yeah there's no time
limit that's right
so uh I'm not following this logic at
all here okay so if
if you're withdrawn from the
um where that money is being used you're
back in public school now right or
wherever you are yeah you don't get any
more deposits how can you then be using
an EFA and attending that public school
if you're attending full-time
it's how you collect both it sounds like
double dipping to me if you've been in
the remember it's the money from the
prior year though if you don't get any
more deposits so imagine I'm just a
student I'm gonna just walk us through
it so we get it okay I have spent an
entire year in the education Freedom
account program homeschooling for
example okay and I was given the grant
of we'll use the average of 4 800 and I
paid for online classes and I paid for
tutoring and I paid for a computer and I
have twenty dollars left in my account
at the end of the year I decide I'm
going to go back to public school for
the fall right I would say I'm
transferring to my public school the
deposits would stop because you're not
re-enrolling in the education Freedom
account so you're not getting any more
money deposited but that twenty dollars
from the prior year is still your Grant
from the prior year so you're allowed to
spend that twenty dollars on a textbook
or a notebook or something that you need
the money you receive in the current
year so you are not in the current year
because you've withdrawn so you don't
get any more deposits
got it
Kinda Yeah sort of okay but you keep the
grant you've been given
so it would be as if a family goes to
your public school right you receive the
adequacy money from the state I mean do
they take it back
at the end of the year if they pay the
April payment to the district and a
child leaves it on May 30th does the
district return it to the state
they don't it's by the payments so if I
keep my forty eight hundred dollars yeah
each year you could keep your if you
could apply that to college if you've
been in it no when you graduate it goes
back to the state
thank you yes you're welcome you got it
yeah
this is fun yeah that is yeah
representative cordelli uh thank you
um how often during the year are
payments made into the EFA account just
like to the public school four times so
remember you won't get a payment if
you've left
okay so you have September November
January April and so say you've now
you've been in the program for a whole
year again we're going to do another
scenario right now it's September and
September I decided I'm gonna stay I'm
gonna go to my private school so that I
get my September deposit so I have last
year I paid for my private school maybe
I carried forward 20 bucks that I didn't
use last year I'm in September I get my
September 20 which is about a thousand
dollars now I have a thousand twenty
say I stay all the way to October 30th
and then I withdraw and go back to the
public school I wouldn't get November
payment or January or April I would
probably pay that thousand dollars I got
for the tuition I owed in my private
school if I had twenty dollars left
there again I could use it for a
notebook going forward
my helper for the question from Balboni
thank you Mr chair just another question
and thank you for taking my question
just because I don't really understand
the way the program works and I'm new
and so I apologize if everyone else
knows this but can you please explain to
me you're talking about a digital wallet
where money is deposited and can move
strong but then again you're also
talking about being reimbursed yes okay
so can you explain the difference we
have time for this
I'm sorry okay great
so technology exists now
where there's a platform
and so it's a digital wallet platform so
it's like PayPal kind of meets Amazon to
to imagine it in your head
so the grant is held in this digital
wallet which is a bank on the back end
okay and the front end is an interface
where you can log in
when you log into your digital wallet
there's three ways you can use it
there's an integrated shopping platform
called The Marketplace which is why when
you look at the expense reports you see
Amazon and Staples and vendors like that
they're integrated into this shopping
platform the benefit for for us from an
administrative standpoint of families
using that shopping platform to buy
their notebooks right in the platform is
again it's all internal and so we look
at it before it goes anywhere so it's as
if we have a pre-approval process so a
family puts things in the carts we look
at the carts look at the skus in the
cart and say these things are allowable
but say this thing is not allowable we
would just say this this cart is not
allowable you've got to make a cart
that's allowable okay so there's a
benefit and then if a family does a
return the money goes right back into
the EFA in the digital wallet so it's
technology exists
the second way a family can use this
money in the digital wallet is through
what they call a direct pay in those
reports you had a list of all those
vendors and schools
so they've been onboarded into the
platform
so you go in and you say I'm going to
pay my school you look for your school
in the list right in the platform then
you're uploading your invoice for the
school in the platform again we're
looking at the invoice and saying is it
is it allowable or not allowable is it a
duplicate right is it is it an error is
there a mistake on it so that if it
doesn't work we say no you can't do that
if it does work we say yes and then the
payment goes directly to the provider
through the digital wallet again it can
go back in to the digital wallet also if
they want to do a return for example
which may be why they're amicable to
doing that Rick because it's it's easy
for them to say okay put this money back
in the child's account but again all of
that stays inside
then there's a third way which is the
reimbursement way and in the law it says
they can do a reimbursement with a
receipt
so you log into the platform you go into
the reimbursement section the families
actually have linked their bank account
on that piece of it they upload a
receipt for something so for example we
see a receipt from Walmart okay my team
Googles the skus on the receipt to make
sure they're all allowable if it's
allowable and we can see that the family
made that out of pocket expense we can
say yes and then the platform directly
reimburses the parent
amazing right I mean it wouldn't be
further questions thank you
thank you Mr chairman I want you this is
the first time
this committee has had a chance to at
least get some briefing on how this
house thing works so I'm happy to be
here representative Myler you know that
but but here's here's the question yeah
see if I'm correct
it sounds like there is not a
disbursement
for anything
without an optimization
from uh one of your staff right human
eyes are on everything yeah so no
nothing gets paid that without some
sense of oversight on that
it's correct that's correct Yeah you
mentioned though the third talk a little
bit more about your third category I
didn't quite understand how the Third
Way the families can use the the
reimbursement capabilities of the
platform yes yeah so for example you've
made a deposit
right at your private school to to
enroll
um and you've done that
um you know before you participate
you're like okay I gotta pay their
tuition they're asking me for the
tuition in July and I don't start school
until September and you paid that
tuition you could get reimbursed for the
tuition that you paid in advance and
that's in the law itself also it says
either we can reimburse them for that or
we could even pay it for them and then
put the money back into their education
Freedom account so I mean the way the
law was written it was so that the
families could use that reimbursement
feature
again we look at every single one of
them those are the hardest to process
because you can imagine I mean they're
very diverse receipts every receipt
looks differently I mean we're Googling
skus on the receipt
and we've done 30 000 orders through
this platform
and you have how many staff do you have
now it takes about 10 people to run this
program okay thank you yeah
representative cordelli thank you thank
you for that explanation
um and my memory may or may not serve me
all the time but Arizona was the first
program in 2011 and we've heard about
fraud and one of the great examples was
Arizona and
um got hit with some very heavy fraud
investigations and charges for the early
program but that was because it was a
manual system that they were trying to
operate am I correct that they have now
you moved to the same platform that we
are using that's right well they're
halfway moved to using um the platform
is called class wallet and they're
halfway to having everything run through
the platform instead of they were using
manual reimbursements and having
families do expense reports and that
just isn't first of all it's not
responsive enough to the families I mean
the whole point of creating this program
is for it to be parent and child Centric
right not to be
make it difficult for them to use it
right and so using the platform makes it
so for example in our law it says they
have to have access to their real-time
balances so that a family can log in and
see what I've what they've used their
money on their Grant and see how much
they have available the only way to do
that would be using this technology and
so Arizona is moving towards using this
technology fully also and again in New
Hampshire we are fiscally responsible
and so it would make sense that we would
choose to design a program that was also
fiscally responsible
thank you are there further questions
sounds to me like it would be very
difficult to even commit fraud and so I
met I just wonder
um in the two years it's been around
have you or a year and a half it's been
around have you discovered any fraud or
attempted fraud
we asked some families some clarifying
questions if we don't understand
something there's a lot of times that we
look at something and we might not know
what it is and so we'll say to them can
you explain to us what this is how does
it align with your curriculum we did
have one family for whom we were
questioning their the receipts in
reimbursement and we did have to
research to to make sure that it was a
legitimate provider that existed that
they were getting the receipts from they
looked a little bit strange to us and so
we wanted to make sure that the store
actually existed you know in some of the
little small towns in New Hampshire
there's tiny stores and we wanted to
make sure the store existed and so we
went to the store we contacted the store
and we were like okay this is a real
store and they just don't have very good
receipts and and so those have been our
experiences so far we haven't referred
someone to the attorney general but as
you've noticed from this discussion we
do take this really seriously and would
refer someone to the attorney general
and freeze their account and reject them
from the program if we thought that they
were because they'd be taking advantage
of us as much as they've been taking
advantage of the taxpayer and that's
unacceptable to us so we would do it but
we haven't had to do that okay we're in
technical questions if somebody has a
technical question to ask of Kate
um let's go for it but we're I want to
close this thing down by 2 30. one more
here thank you
um I'd love to get outlines uh oh come
on you're having fun
um 28 to 30.
um talks about investigation sure um the
example you just gave of um contacting
that little store about the receipt and
so forth yeah
um I would think that that would be an
example of an investigation you're doing
to make sure that there is no fraud
involved yeah and that part is crossed
out in this bill I mean there's four
pages of of the parent handbook that
pertain to this and I don't have them
all memorized so I can't tell you all of
the steps that we go through but because
that was such a big piece of the law
it's a big piece of the rules also we do
have a whole process and and Matt isn't
here but Matt would be the one to lead
that process in his role as director of
policy and compliance in our
organization
and thank you it's laid out in the
parent handbook if you do want to read
it okay this is going to be the last
question folks represent Balboni
thank you Mr chair
um just one last question again being
new to the whole program what there's a
lot of talk about the 10 and so there's
two questions regarding the ten percent
um one is is the 10 above the adequacy
amount that you get and the second
question is there's been some talk about
how as the program gets more efficient
that 10 cost May decrease so can you
speak to that sure yeah absolutely so
what it says in the law is up to 10 and
yes from the from the adequacy so it's
not above the adequacy so say a family
gets a grant of
four thousand dollars right the amount
that we could use for administrative
costs is four hundred dollars and the
family would get the grant of how's my
math thirty six hundred dollars okay so
when the family receives the grant the
cost of getting that Grant to them and
all the technology and the people is is
not there already and yes it's up to ten
percent so last year even with all the
startup costs we were at 9.8 and yes Our
intention is to run it for as little as
possible administrative costs so be
great if we could get down to five or
six the digital wallet platform we have
to pay for that is a big part of the
total cost of the program because while
it's
fabulous it's not inexpensive
and so we're already running if you take
your 10 you divide it up between the
cost of my humans and the work that
they're doing and the digital wallet you
know we're running closer to seven or
eight already because two or three is
the digital wallet cost
okay if there are any other questions
for representative cordelli ask them a
Kate after the hearing okay
okay is everybody good thank you very
much my pleasure yeah
happy to be of assistance I don't have
any other pink cards on this one so with
that I'm going to close this hearing and
we're going to start the next one up in
great
sorry
copy of 538 uh if you don't I've got a
couple extras up here on the table
okay we're ready to go it's uh 2 30.
and these last bill of this afternoon
it's 5 38 establishing a local education
Freedom account program uh
representative verbill Welcome to our
committee
thank you Mr chairman uh members of the
committee uh for some of you this is
going to be like deja vu all over again
uh but new and improved even even better
than than last time for the record I'm
representative Kevin varavel of
Rockingham second district serving the
communities of Auburn Deerfield and
Candia first a little background of me
for those of you that don't know me I'm
a New Hampshire native I was raised in
Pembroke New Hampshire where I attended
Pembroke public schools from grade one
through grade eight I attended Bishop
Brady High School in Concord I received
a Bachelor of Science in physical
science secondary education with a
chemistry option for Plymouth State
College yep that's how old I am it was a
college back then I attended graduate
school at Tulane University in New
Orleans Louisiana and uh I held an
experienced educator certificate in
physical science and chemistry from the
New Hampshire Department of Education
and was certified to teach grades 7
through 12 right there it was a high
school science teacher in North Andover
High School in North Andover
Massachusetts and at Hollis Brookline
High School in Hollis New Hampshire I'm
currently the technical director for
Summit Packaging Systems in Manchester
New Hampshire I'm product of public
schools and private schools both
religious and and non-secular schools
my wife though she doesn't like me to
mention her in these speeches is a
Spanish teacher working in a New
Hampshire public school and my two
daughters attend public high schools in
New Hampshire
House Bill 538 is relative to public
education and before we can discuss
public education we should understand
clearly what public education is public
education in New Hampshire means that
each local community has an obligation
to educate the children of their
community
inherent in this responsibility is the
Public Funding for the education of all
local children
so when we speak of public education we
are speaking of who is responsible for
financing that education that's why
today that is what today's discussion is
about it's not about uh how or where our
community will provide that education
but rather how they will fund it should
not be a discussion about this school or
that school or this method or that
method those those are those things are
a separate conversation
before we get to the particulars uh
particular details of this bill I want
you to consider the following
there are no public schools in New
Hampshire
that's right
there are no public schools in New
Hampshire what we have is a large number
of private schools that have been
granted unilateral claim to public
education monies let us consider my
hometown at Deerfield as a case in point
the Deerfield Community School our local
public school is not really a public
school it is not available to the
General Public
it is in fact a private school for
Deerfield children
if your child does not reside in
Deerfield it is all but impossible for
your child to attend the Deerfield
Community School
Deerfield is a small school district so
it would not be completely unfair to
suggest that it does not provide
sufficient evidence of the previous
claim fair enough let us consider larger
public school districts such as Concord
Manchester Nashua Etc many districts
have more than one and often several
schools that teach the same grade within
their Community boundaries
both these school but these schools each
providing an education for children of
the same grade level are not freely
available to all the children in that
Community currently in those grades
children must attend the school in their
District assigned to them based on the
child's home address those schools are
not Public Schools those schools are
private schools for students living
within a very specific and limited
geographical area
this is an important notion to keep in
mind current and modern thinking on
education is to provide that which is in
the best interest of the student
and I agree with that it is hard to
imagine that requiring attendance at a
particular School based on a student's
address will provide students with the
education that meets their particular
and individual best interests
it's also interesting to consider
special education in this discussion
children in the special education system
each receive an IEP and individualized
education plan to ensure the child
receives an individualized education
that is in the best interest of the
student further those requiring the most
specialized individual education plan
are often sent to or tuitioned into
private schools most of which are out of
District that are capable of providing
for the needs that that student that are
in that student's best interest
so the concept and practice of using
local taxpayer education Monies to send
students to private institutions for a
public education is already in common
practice
in fact my hometown of Deerfield is a
public school for pre-k through grade
eight
we do not have a high school
there's a high school in our SAU but
Deerfield the Deerfield School District
currently does not send any students
there we tuition all of our students to
Heist all of our high school students
out of district and out of our SAU
primarily Concord Concord is uh is where
we send the vast majority of our
students and a few attend other schools
so school choice is nothing new what
we're about to just discuss is crew
should be allowed to make the decision
who should get to make the choice for a
particular student that is what I hope
we'll be discussing today
House Bill 538 enact establishing local
education Freedom account program is
enabling legislation
in New Hampshire we value we treasure
local control and we have a long history
of supporting legislation that grants
our communities local control local
decision making
this bill grants vocal control to decide
if local education monies should be
allowed to follow the child
the mechanisms contained within this
bill already exist and can be found in
existing rsas first the question is
defined in the bill shall we adopt the
provisions of RSA 194g to allow the
establishment of local education Freedom
account program and insert your local
District this ensures that the question
is stated clearly and concisely and
cannot be altered for any reason that
way the voters know what they're voting
on
the real the repeal language is also
defined in the bill and it asks that the
question in the in the opposite
the enactment
the repeal requires a three-fifths a
sixty percent vote in the affirmative by
local voters
that is the local voters will get to
decide whether or not this is what they
want to do in their school district
this sets a reasonable threshold for a
community to make this decision and it
is a threshold that is used in other
existing ballot messages such as going
from traditional town meeting to sb2 or
back from sb2 back to traditional town
meeting okay
the threshold to place the question on
the ballot is low buy and this by Design
to ensure easy access to enable local
control again these thresholds already
exist in other statutes and there is no
value in setting an artificially High
barrier to access uh to ask a clear and
succinct question to discern the will of
the people in such a matter
the computation of local education funds
this is where we're going to depart from
what we discussed uh previously in the
last session we talked about this the
local education Freedom account shall be
funded by The Local District at an
original amount equal to twice the per
pupil adequate education grant amount
under RSA 198 colon 40-a plus any
differentiated Aid that would have been
provided to a public school for that
eligible student
it's estimated that the state adequacy
Grant funds approximately 20 percent of
a public education in the average school
district in New Hampshire so this
program would make 40 percent of that
money available to follow the child
leaving 60 percent of the money in the
local school district
state
adequacy Grant is currently and I had to
revise my notes a little bit currently
about forty eight hundred dollars per
student so thank you Mr Speaker for
staying back
thus making uh about ninety six hundred
dollars available to follow the student
this is enough money to allow virtually
any New Hampshire family to select the
educational opportunities that they
believe in the best is in the best
interest of their children
this program would be a fiscal win-win
for both students families and local
school districts
a student enrolled in this program is
counted in the average daily membership
and attendance calculation and therefore
All State monies associated with that
child continue to flow to the local
school district this also means that the
state and local EFA programs are
mutually exclusive a student could not
participate in both
okay special education monies are left
entirely intact and untouched Federal
monies are left intact and untouched
large part of the discussion on hb20
which is our current EFA uh bill was the
grant would not be sufficient to allow
lower income earners to access other
educational options well I would posit
that every little bit helps to be sure
this bill directly addresses that issue
and provided Grant sufficient to allow
even the most economically challenged
families to access a very broad spectrum
of alternative opportunities
that being said it would be a shame if
the debate on this bill devolved into a
discussion of class conflict public
education is providing the funding for
the education of all children in the
community using public resources all
children should have the same and equal
right to lay claim to an equal share of
the publicly raised regular education
funds regardless of the family's
financial status
after all we don't charge rich kids more
money to attend the local public school
if a community chooses to allow local
education Monies to follow the child why
would we alter that equal access social
contract
there's been a lot of discussion
relative to the expected effects of
school choice on local school districts
let us consider some facts I believe
that most families prefer that their
children attend the local school
district
I believe this to be true for a few
reasons first and foremost most families
want their children to be raised with a
sense of community and for their
children to be connected to that
Community most families want their
children to know their neighbors and the
local school The Local District school
is often the most efficient way of
achieving this goal
that is a reason most families want
their children to attend local school
districts
is transportation
in New Hampshire we require district
schools to provide student
transportation to and from the local
District school through grade 8. this is
not an insignificant benefit for most
families for attending their local
District school a family that chooses to
leave the local school district for
whatever reason independently and under
this program would lose the benefit of
free transportation for the sake of
brevity lastly most families believe
that their local school district
provides a good education for their
children why would a family choose to
leave a local school district if their
needs are already being met so for those
that say this would cause a mass Exodus
out of the local public schools I would
say that that that that that simply
should not be the case and if it is
while the school district should think
about why that is
fact of the matter is no school no one
school can provide what is in the best
interest of every student in the
district there is no one-size-fits-all
so for some students an alternative
opportunity is in the best interest of
the student and we should always strive
for what is in the best interest of the
student
New Hampshire has some of the best
public schools in the country
nobody refutes that fact
but going back to 2008 and looking at
kneecap smarter balance and New
Hampshire SAS New Hampshire Public
School students as a group rarely break
50 percent at or above Proficiency in
English language arts
mathematics or science this is also a
fact a stark and stunning fact so while
we may have some of the best public
schools in the nation we are still on
average missing the mark for half of our
students
this bill requires to provide an annual
record of educational attainment by
having the student take the Statewide
student assessment test pursuant to RSA
193-6 C colon six so the previous
version of this Bill had multiple
versions to show academic attainment and
that was one of the criticisms from the
other side of the aisle on the previous
version of the bill and I took that
criticism to heart and so this bill has
simply the Statewide assessment as the
vehicle just like we do for public
schools
okay so that's it's the same assessment
vehicle if you want to participate in a
local EFA that's what you do
it's interesting to know once you enter
post-secondary education in America then
we transition to 100 school choice
environment and look how good that
system works the diversity in schools
and programs is all but unparalleled and
meets the needs of almost all
interestingly we do not try to block
taxpayer money in the form of Pell
Grants and student loans or other
financial assistance from flowing to
private colleges or universities to
religious colleges or and universities
this program is a little different than
that with respect to where we allow tax
the allegation that there will be an
exodus of students from the local school
district to other opportunities is not
really a possibility at least not in the
near future
right so why is that the reason for that
is simple there's really no available
slots in any non-public school in New
Hampshire there might be a few but there
aren't many they have all been taken
during the last several years as parents
seek out other options to best fit their
needs with respect to responses to covet
19.
so the available uh inventory is very
very limited except for homeschooling
which is essentially unlimited which is
an option but it's not an option that
that works for the vast majority of
families it just doesn't so it's not
unreasonable to expect that the
inventory of available slots in
education settings will increase to meet
the demand but that process will take
time Market forces are wonderful things
to determine customer customer demands
if a district if a district school sees
it as losing students for to other
educational settings then that's an
indication that they have not provided
the product the service they're
customer-based desires and that would be
the students
if this occurs then the district school
has one of two options stay the course
and lose more and more of their
customers to the competition or retool
and provide the product the service that
their customer base desires this is the
critical feedback loop that is currently
missing from our public education system
because we have continued to winnow our
so
because it's late in the day I'll I'll
sort of cut part of it short but the
American public education system is a
wonderful thing to be sure but American
public education is and should continue
to be a lot more than just a local
public school
let us do what's in the best interest in
New Hampshire children New Hampshire
students and not confine ourselves to
what is in the best interest of a
particular institution or a building
public education is after all the Public
Funding of the education of our children
Mr chair Mr chairman and members of the
committee I thank you for your time and
consideration and I would be happy to
answer any questions thank you very much
representative I got one question for
you if a student receives one of your
local efas here can they also apply for
they can do it with the other EFA
program you can the education tax credit
is one where we the money you know where
that comes from yes I I do I I believe
the answer is yes I I would honestly I
would have to double check so the way
that this bill is written is it largely
mirrors uh the mechanics of our current
EFA program so this this bill doesn't
look to recreate the wheel as to how an
EFA works this bill is simply making
um a potential availability of local
funds to be able to follow the student
it sounds like you can do it I would say
I would say yes and if I find out I'm in
Heir I'd be more than happy thank you to
confess for the questions representative
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
bringing this to our attention
a couple questions this is an I believe
this is enabling legislation correct yes
so so
you answer the question the answer is
yes
um how do you how is the if this if a
school district were to authorize this
by a three-fifths vote
uh how is the EFA then going to be
managed it's managed locally
no so it so it's it's a 60 vote to
enable and if they enable any kid that
participates any student that
participates is grandfathered in so if
they repeal the program the kids that
are in it stay in it till they graduate
high school that's just to keep the
playing field level the the way the bill
is currently written the school district
would write a check to a a
organization that runs the scholarship
so basically New Hampshire Scholarship
Foundation or an organization something
like that the school district would
write the check to that District as the
grant into their EFA and then it would
be managed just like the state PFA
I'm confused if I may yes go ahead I'm
confused so
um the local school district says we're
going to do this and you've got four
kids who say they want to take advantage
of it yep uh walk me through then how
the 9 600 is going to be paid out what's
the accountability of where the money's
going Etc does that check go are you
saying now goes to the state EFA program
no no okay I apologize if if I'm making
this more sound more confusing than it
is
this bill says and I don't know the
exact date I can look it up but
basically by the second week in July the
local school district
would cut a check to a scholarship
organization that manages efas so it
would it would be managed under the same
rules and regulations that our current
state EFA is operating under the only
thing that's changing is who's cutting
the check so instead of the state
cutting the check to the Scholarship
Foundation it's the local school
district cutting the check and instead
of being cut into into bytes into four
distributions it's uh front loaded into
into the account
so it does go to the state and in this
instance the children's scholarship fund
and they then manage that check is that
correct correct just like they do with
the stadium thank you thank you my
friend further questions from the
committee
but you can't let me off that easy
can you tell me if if uh your community
you said you tuition all your grades 9
through 12 to Concord
so we we're coming to the end of a
second 10-year contract with Concord
High School and our contract reads that
we guarantee to send 90 at least 90
percent of our public high school
students to Concord so 10 can be
assigned
um elsewhere
legally we could assign half of our kids
elsewhere but then we'd be paying a
double tuition we'd still be paying a
tuition to Concord even though the
student isn't going there so right now
it's a a 90 minimum threshold leaving 10
which
um my interpretation as the district is
using that for manifest hardship best
interest of the student out of District
placements thank you
any further questions represent Balboni
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
um
it two questions really if that's okay
um one is you said that it's already in
the stature statutes right now that if a
community wants to do this they can no
no I'm sorry so the the mechanism to
enable and disable and the the way that
the the question goes on to the ballot
is pre-existing in other parts of New
Hampshire law so there's there's already
precedent for doing it this way that has
served our state very very well for for
decades so the the idea that the ballot
question is defined in law we we do that
on a lot of questions there's a lot of
Warrant articles that are defined by law
and therefore can't be amended all you
can do is ask the question and see what
the voters say the 60 threshold
um is pre-existing in law the the
example I know the best is to be for a
small community to move from traditional
town meeting to what we consider sb2
type of local governance and and back
um is that 60
threshold it could be set to 51 you know
a majority you could have a you could
have a simple majority the idea of the
60 is to show you know a high degree of
support for whichever direction the
community is choosing to to move so so
for Community to enable this you have to
give 60 in the affirmative uh if a
community so so there's there's people
that say well you know it's a it's a
runaway fiscal train and you're going to
bankrupt the school
I don't believe that'll happen I really
don't
but if it did there's an escape Clause
right so all of a sudden your tax bill
is mushrooming because the cost is
spiraling out of control because God
only you know whatever set of
circumstance creates that a 60 repeals
the program
so if Community decides to try it and
they're doing it and they go you know
actually now that we're doing it it
really we found out it really doesn't
work for us you you can disable the
program uh and go back to doing what you
were doing
and follow up yes directly to what
you've just said though but in the bill
that's written on your the school
district is still responsible
um it forever until the child ages out
of high school for the amount so that
doesn't really change the financial
obligation of the district so so
I I disagree with that I understand your
logic I understand where you're coming
from so we have to make it fair for
everybody it has to be fair for the
district but it also has to be fair for
students and families right so if a town
enables a program like this
and a student avails himself of it and
they find the the best educational fit
for them and the child is thriving and
doing really really well and then the
community decides now we're not going to
do this anymore for whatever reason
right to then say to that child hey you
know those four great years you just had
really glad you enjoyed that we've
changed our mind you're you're going
back here that
that to me
is unfair to the child
and to the family and so it and it's not
forever right it's it's to the age of 20
or to graduation from high school so it
it does time out it does unwind itself
it winds itself down
um over time the the other thing I I
didn't mention that is worth mentioning
right is the first year a child of proof
is approved into the program that is a
minimum Grant
okay and the reason that's a minimum
Grant is because you don't want families
all of a sudden getting half of what
they thought they were getting and now
now they can't do what they want to do
because the the financials haven't
worked so the grants are recalculated
each year and it can go up and down but
for a particular child it can never drop
below the first year grant that way the
families know what their financial floor
is right that this is this is a point
where we're guaranteed and we don't drop
below that so it's to allow a certain
amount of
um of fairness and where this is is tied
to State adequacy you know one would
expect it'll stay relatively consistent
for Fairly large chunks of time uh
without giant fluctuations
thank you thank you for the question
not seeing thank you very much thank you
yeah
thank you Mr chairman my name is David
Trumbull I'm from where I am opposed to
this bill for a few reasons first of all
I think that it misstates the duty of
Education
the state of New Hampshire has the duty
to educate children in the state not the
towns the the presenter of the bill said
that it's up to our towns to educate our
children it's their Duty that's not the
case the Supreme Court looked at the
Constitutional Amendment about education
and said it is the state's duty to
educate the children and that's why the
Claremont decision has been so
contentious because the state has
shifted 80 percent of the cost to the
towns the towns run the schools the
towns are stuck with 80 percent of the
bill but the duty to educate is the
states it is not the town's duty to do
that the second you know the other thing
that was said was that we don't have any
public schools in New Hampshire I mean
obviously our state laws disagree with
that for example RSA 19338 says that all
the public schools in the state cannot
discriminate there's a difference
between a public school and a private
school that's the differentiation so
that the fact that a child from a
different town does can't automatically
go to a school in another town doesn't
mean that other Town School is not a
public school it is a public school by
Statute it is a public school it's our
common understanding of what a public
school is
the second reason that I object to this
bill is that I think it will cause
significant harm to our local schools
the amount of five thousand dollars of
uh times two gets to 9 600 and that's
going to go up so let's call it ten
thousand in his school district that is
only spending and the speaker said well
that's only 40 percent of this this
town's spending that may be true
Statewide but in the poorer communities
it's way more than 40 percent in my town
we spend 16 000 for a child 10 000 over
16 is like 65 percent ish so losing that
money will seriously that
schools that are the subject of the
Claremont law school these are the
schools that can't afford to lose that
amount of money what will they end up
doing when they have this cut they're
going to have to get rid of all the
programs that make their school hold
together after school programs bullying
programs gifted programs French and
Spanish are music and phys Ed they're
all going to get lost because they won't
have the funds after this money is
withdrawn
the other issue on the local schools
that I think this bill misunderstands
what a school is a school is run as a
long-term proposition people move into a
town because they want to be part of the
community and that means having their
children go to the school in that town
the people who run the schools the
school boards spend tremendous amounts
of volunteer time to run the schools to
run them as long-term institutions this
goes to when do we build a new school
when do we upgrade our athletic grounds
building a sense of community in the
school building policies so that we
teach this in this grade and moves on to
this grade there's a lot of work that
goes into building a school sense of
community this bill doesn't respect that
because when that money gets sucked out
of those schools the schools won't be
able to maintain that sense of community
so I understand the bill says well what
about this child who really wants to go
someplace special but what about all the
families who moved into a town and lived
there and they want to maintain the
basic school that already exists there
this bill will gut our local schools
it's basically an attempt to do to the
whole state what almost happened in
Croydon last year and we should avoid
doing that because that is a shallow
concept of the social contract we should
have a deeper
conception of our social contract to
each other that we start with the basics
which is our public school which brings
me to the third reason I object to this
bill there's no data that indicates that
this program works we've got a pilot
program with 80 some odd percent of the
students in it were already in private
schools you have just a couple hundred
at most children who have moved from one
school to another and now we want to
redo the entire New Hampshire education
system with bills from this morning that
could easily cost 100 or 200 million
dollars and this one now turns our local
schools into taking over the state's
role of being responsible to running the
duty to educate it makes no sense to do
that unless you know it works this
morning I was reading a little bit of
evidence to you about some of the issues
with the uh
Choice programs scholarship programs
voucher programs no disrespect is meant
by using the word voucher just that's
the word that the education literature
is uses but I will reduce something from
Indiana this is from the center for tax
and budget accountability they studied
Indiana school choice scholarship and
what they said was basically it's going
to divert public tax dollars away from
the state's higher performing public
schools to the lower performing private
religious schools they said well what's
going on in other countries this issue
came up it's they read this is a quote
the Nations that have been most
successful in improving student
achievement over time and focused on
systems-based reforms that build
capacity of the overall education system
and have astewed reforms based on
competition and choice meanwhile Nations
that have taken the competition Choice
path to education reform have failed to
realize enhanced student achievement and
that's really the fundamental problem
with this bill we've got a pilot project
that doesn't work it hasn't worked
around the country it hasn't worked
around the world we're going to upturn
our complete education system to do it
because some people think education is
like buying coffee or other products
it's not a product it's the way we build
our communities is through our schools
so this bill basically tries to say the
schools become sort of like well it's
just it's built on the concept of
competition and I think that is the
fundamental flaw in this bill we should
look at our schools as the foundation of
our communities instead thank you thank
you are there any questions from the
committee
they don't miss the chairman not seeing
okay yeah
good afternoon chairman and members of
the committee glad to be back here again
uh I am the President of American
Federation of teachers New Hampshire and
I am here to speak on behalf of our 4
000 members and the 165 000 Public
Schools students in New Hampshire I was
a little surprised to hear there's no
such thing as public school I would
disagree about that
um and we are here opposing HP 538 I
would agree with the speaker right
before me who said that is the state's
obligation to provide public education
and uh to fund it adequately HP 538
would create a local voucher program and
it could easily decimate our local
neighborhood Public Schools it would
leave our students with only a
threadbare education
when you have students leaving your
local schools for
choice
and taking the funding with them the
things that get cut first are the things
that make the schools vibrant the things
that make schools valuable I was just
having a discussion with the gentleman
back there who is on his local school
board and they're facing increased class
sizes loss of paraprofessionals because
their state aid has been cut back
those are the things that go first music
art student learning support Library
Transportation Sports I'll be on the
chopping block
uh as local communities struggle to keep
up with cutbacks because as we have
heard over and over again there really
isn't further to go with property taxes
taxpayers are Tapped Out
you can't dig into Pockets that are
already empty and and
um there's just no further you can go
um unlike the state voucher program this
program has no income eligibility
restrictions which means you're going to
be asking struggling families to reach
into their pockets to pay for you know
someone to go to St Paul's or Phillips
Exeter and that's just not fair
Grant State families want quality
stability and predictability and they
get that with their local neighborhood
Public Schools they don't want to take a
chance on the promise of maybe
an option being developed in competition
in the future of something better that
could come on the horizon they want
schools that they know they want schools
that they have a say in a voice in
through their school boards and they
they want predictability this program
would have the opposite effect and could
lead to a Bare Bones education instead
of the robust education that our
students deserve and that they are
getting in their neighborhood public
schools and for those reasons we are
opposing HB 538
and Brookstone cordelli yep thank you
thank you for sticking around
um I I think you mentioned um students
leaving for Choice
um programs and the effects that it had
with various programs at local school
but what about the children who leave
for other reasons I know in my local
school district
last year 104 students left enrollment
dropped by 104 students but only 21 left
for Education Freedom accounts 83 left
for
other reasons
um so I'm not sure how we would Define
the trouble on those 21 students leaving
causing disruption to the programs in in
the district
What can you
explain I can't explain something with
that amount of information because it's
hard to
um
you know it's hard to really answer a
question with so little information if
you're talking about students leaving
and taking funding with them then you
have to take apart programs and
therefore you are not providing what the
rest of the students are expect and
their families are expecting in their
schools
yeah
but
students will leave for non-choice
reasons the funding goes away for them
the the
those questions I'm having difficulty
with picturing what your example means
so the 84 students who left for
non-choice reasons the following year
the state money would go away for those
students also
right
so it's not so funding disappears if a
child leaves for whatever reason
isn't that the case
that would seem to be the case yes I'm
still trying to work through
leaving for non-choice reasons but maybe
we can have a conversation later and you
can explain in more detail what you mean
thank you okay
I I have a question for you
um
we know that there are students in
schools that are undergoing daily
repeated bullying
we know that there are schools that are
at the bottom of the proficiency levels
in mathematics and reading
and we know that a child's in the fourth
grade just once in their life they're
nine years old once do you believe the
parent then should seek out
alternative education for their child or
keep them in that bullying situation or
that situation where they're not
learning any mathematics
so there are several other options for
how to address each of those situations
and you know there are
currently ways to uh deal with
persistent bullying including requesting
a manifest hardship if it reaches that
far without any
um resolution when you work through the
process before that
um but how does
having a town-wide vote that can lead to
dismantling the public school for
everyone in town help the situation
for the questions
from the committee
do we have any other pink cards on the
news film
I guess we have no for the pink cards on
the bill so this uh hearing is over
completed
and we are done the bills for today
however I want to really let everybody
on the committee know that on the 24th
we have those bills set for hearing that
are already in the calendar but I will
be announcing on the floor
tomorrow that we will be exacting
certain bills also on that day so keep
your ears open so you can understand
which bills which we will be exacting on
the 24th we have problem as of the 24th
we will have 93 hearings in this
committee and approximately 50 of our
exec sessions are complete that leaves
50 roughly or 47 to go still so
um got away so we're going to have to
really try to get make use of every
moment we have and I'd like to do that
on the 24th as well
so
have a good evening and don't get caught
up in the blizzard if you're going to be
um identifying those particular bills
they're going to be executing on our
Friday you just email us no I I've
already contacted represent Miler with
the six bills which we are going to be
doing thank you I wouldn't be a bit
surprised too to see something that's
pulled off what we had today
put on to that that docket thank you
that's where they come from the sixth
given to him or the bills possibly from
here good thank you
what do I do with these
you got the purple folder yeah they're
right there yeah just sticking in the
purple folder and then they'll take care
of either Lindsay or Jen will take care